ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states has
announced
that he has cancer
okay the bit's over here you go you have
glasses back
uh he actually did
and i felt like we needed a dramatic
opener and i was like i need glasses and
he was like where are my glasses i was
like we got to do a dramatic moment
here's the thing if joe biden's brain
worked i'd take it seriously and the
issue is i don't think his brain works
so when he says that he had cancer i
kind of feel like he probably doesn't
but i don't know because maybe he does
and maybe that's why his brain doesn't
work what a crazy world that we live in
i got to be completely honest it is it
is absolutely insane that the president
came out gave a speech and said i
and so damn many other people have
cancer and he was making a reference to
uh to the oil industry and stuff and
it's just like wait wait a minute
everyone's like bro what you have cancer
and then the white house comes out
they're like no no no no
he had cancer and it's like whoa by net
cancer when well just before he got
elected you didn't tell us the president
well it was
okay this story is getting a little
crazy so we're gonna have to break that
one down and then there's other big news
apparently hunter biden is actually
facing criminal charges for tax
avoidance and over the gun in delaware
so i'm just kind of like yo i gotta be
honest you you go after him for the gun
thing i'll have a little bit more faith
in the government to be completely
honest not like i have any to begin with
but a little bit maybe maybe you won't
be such a double standard
i i still can't believe that uh joe
biden said that he has cancer so uh yeah
anyway
we're going to talk about that but
before we get started
head over to strongerbonesandlife.com
and pick up your ageless multi-collagen
collagen is really good for you need it
for your joint your hair your skin your
nails it keeps your skin looking young
and youthful it's actually really really
good for you i kind of messed my hand up
so i should probably be eating more of
this but i skate a lot so i really do
appreciate dropping the stuff in my
drinks every so often make a smoothie
maybe but i haven't really been doing a
lot of sugar so kind of just mix it in
water and stuff head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com you'll get a 60
60 day money back guarantee from
biotrust the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources essential to optimally
support an array of full body benefits
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits and for every
order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org today biotrust
has provided over 5 million 5 million
meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth there's no clumping unlike other
supplements you'll get free shipping
with every order free vip live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust team
of expert nutrition and health coaches
for life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every or every order shout out
biotrust for sponsoring the show you
know we're big fans we really do
appreciate it don't forget to head over
to timcast.com
click that join us button become a
member
yo we announced that we were bringing
cast castle
to the website exclusive like any other
streaming video service and the response
was unfortunate people saying i don't
want to be a member because i don't like
paypal and it's unfortunate because we
booted paypal from the website now if
you're already a member and you use
paypal you're fine you're still a member
if you sign up now we're using dan
bongino's parallel economy it's
associated with rumble and den bonjour
is one of the co-founders they are an
anti-censorship payment processor
service so rest assured you don't have
to give money to people who hate you we
are doing everything we can to help
build up this alternate ecosystem that's
anti-censorship a diverse array of
opinions so we are extremely excited to
be using parallel economy when you
become a member today you are helping me
you're helping dan bongino you're
helping rumble you're helping parallel
economy you are building up this system
so we can say screw you to the sensors
that's the first step it's not as big as
paypal we're not as big as disney plus
we got to start somewhere so what we're
going to do is we're putting cast castle
we're making 22 minute episodes like any
other sitcom
start a little rough around the edges
but give us time we're getting it better
and better we're working on making a
legitimate good funny comedy show we've
also got tales from the inverted world
hour-long episodes exploring the lost
confederate gold and more to come comedy
specials documentaries more podcasts and
news shows coming your way we got pop
culture crisis of course support our
work and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends today joining
us to talk about all this we got danny
farar
thank you all for having us on i
appreciate it i actually listen you
talking about the bone broth what i love
about you is you're actually investing
back in your people you're giving them
dag on financial compensation for going
to the gym and getting shredded so now
not only will they be smart they'll even
look better as well so hats off to you
man i appreciate it oh yeah so uh you're
you're with soldierfit you want to
explain that yeah so soldier fit is a
business i started when i got back from
uh iraq or a functional fitness gym and
then i also had the non-profit platoon
22 which we started off as a suicide
awareness
movement started after the second
soldier from frederick county committed
suicide and really what we've morphed
into now is best in class transition we
raised a million dollars to build the
first ever platoon veterans services
center which will be in a 45-minute
drive of 70 of maryland's veterans and
we look to take this national from here
so we'll be opening november 10th if
anybody wants to come out and really
gonna provide best-in-class transitional
support for our warfighters right on and
what you were mentioning before is like
i've never i don't think i've ever
mentioned this but uh you do a fitness
thing soldier fit and then you actually
have a bunch of our employees doing
physical fitness and training yeah uh
our good friend luke had you come out
and do it and did this big thing and
then i said to everybody who does it
we'll give you a bonus we'll give you
100 bucks for doing this once a week and
uh yeah people have been
keeping it up so they're they're gonna
they're coming for your money man i mean
they're in there monday tuesday thursday
friday the way i see it is
someone who is healthy and fit is more
productive
and they're they're gonna be happier
they're going to be healthier it's
better for them it's better for me so
we'll we'll throw them a bonus for
staying fit i can actually get you a
number on that wilco
has actually broke that number down to
for every dollar that you invest in your
employee's health you'll receive a three
dollar return on your investment and
reduction in sick call uh sick days
increased productivity as you talked
about there drops in your insurance
rates so you know hey it's a it's a good
investment me it's kind of just
i think it's kind of more political
personal i just think people should be
healthy and do what they can and so when
i saw people were into it i was like
let's we'll throw you a hundred bucks a
week for every time you do this thing
and so right on man thanks for joining
us thanks for having us we also got
hannah claire do you want to introduce
yourself hi i'm here claire brimlo can
you hear me i'm a writer for timcast.com
actually that's right i will apparently
be signing up for soldierfit i did not
realize we got a bonus for this i've
been running on the trail like a
hooligan sucker i mean a bear could get
you you weren't out so it was like
everybody was outside and luke was like
you know get in shape yelling at people
i remember hearing this happen but the
thing that happens to me is i get sucked
into the news cycle and spend a lot of
time just at my computer so i actually
probably need to be at ultrafit i pulled
up to my bike and danny was like get in
here and luke was like come on tim and i
was like i don't got time for this i'm
too busy yeah but i'll give all of you a
hundred dollars that's right for doing
this and everyone's like yeah like i dig
it yeah everyone who does it comes into
the office and they're like oh yeah do
you we did that thing this morning like
they're super intense they're hyped up
so they chest bumps yeah yeah
it's like a lot of voices got deeper
yeah
yeah so maybe i'll renounce running and
honestly my biggest thing is for women
to lift i think women need to lift more
than men do if i'm honest
well okay i'll see you at solar face all
right 6 30 tomorrow morning that's 100
uh hey guys ian crossland my
girlfriend's actually just got back from
a lifting session earlier today maybe
i'll uh turn around to your gym this is
very impressive uh ian crossland.net
happy to see you let's get going andy
has been going to soldierfit every
morning that he can some mornings he
doesn't get it's just become part of our
morning he comes back he's all hype he
said today he lifted like 380 pounds i
was like i don't believe you and he
showed me the video and i was like what
the heck is going on over there so
they're having a great time over there
so i'm delighted to have danny
right on everybody let's get into this
first story possibly one of the biggest
stories of our generation
joe biden says he has cancer thanks to
the oil industry
and then i love how they add this
but white house points to skin cancer
years ago
okay okay hold on there a minute joe
biden said he had cancer i mean the
remark initially appeared to be a
stunningly casual health announcement
during a speech about global warming in
which the president described emissions
from oil refineries near his childhood
home in claim uh claymont delaware quote
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up with have cancer
and why for the longest time delaware
had the highest cancer rate in the
nation
white house spokesman andrew bates
referred the post to a tweet from
washington post columnist glenn kessler
who noted that biden had non-melanoma
skin cancers removed before he took
office
i don't buy it look i get it joe biden's
brain ain't all with it and maybe he
just gaffed but to have this like
the spokesman pointed to a journalist
who pointed to a claim yeah i don't
understand why he couldn't just say
himself like this is what happened to
the president if they really did remove
the melanomas or whatever like why do
you have to refer to the washington post
you are the original source for this he
didn't have his note cards yeah okay
right yeah that's an important part
yeah he didn't know what to say
now look look look joe biden gaffes all
the time so i'm not going to sit here
and be like this is the one time he
wasn't guessing like no literally
everything on his mouth is probably
gibberish nonsense so
i don't know what this means but there's
two kinds of gaffes there's the
accidental blurring of the truth gaff
and then there's the churning on the
shabbat a pressure gap yeah which one is
this gotta be the truth people don't you
don't accidentally tell people you have
cancer
anyone i've never met anyone anyone i
mean i don't know people that are
suffering from dementia and alzheimer's
i don't know a lot of them and maybe
they say things like that yeah if they
had it they still think they have it but
then if that's an indication of his
alzheimer's or dementia that's another
problem altogether it's one or the other
either he's being honest or he's
blatantly lying to people for sympathy
which i don't think is the reason well
and it's a problem that it's present
tense right i didn't he's not saying i
had cancer he's saying i have it so
that's sort of a strange thing to not
take an immediately immediate strong
response from i i think
i think he's i think he slipped out the
truth maybe let me let me play this clip
i think uh let me see if it'll play
properly there we go
okay does it make me go to twitter all
right
oh here we go i always have the wrong
button click nice aviators joe nice idea
for lane highway
that was accessible my mother drove us
and rather than us be able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window that's why i and so damn many
other people i grew up have cancer and
why can't for the longest time delaware
had the highest cancer rate in the
nation
so
you know what makes me think it's
possibly him spreading out the truth is
his indignation
like his anger
you know like if it was something he had
a long time ago if he got cancer he's
talking about when he was young what he
got skin melanomas 70 years after he
left
you know what i mean so
so it sounds to me more like
this might be a he's just his brain fog
and then he just says it says it without
look i mean
if he had cancer it could explain a
whole lot it could explain literally why
he gaffs so much well i mean i think the
thing is crazy about nowadays is you
would have never thought 10 15 20 years
ago that we would have information this
readily available and they would still
be able to twist it as to and change the
narrative of what it is you know this
isn't something that's heard second or
third party this is literally broadcast
nationally internationally at the time
and then instantaneously we just say
it's something different let's think
about how crazy it is if the story is he
doesn't have cancer the president
accidentally told the world he has
cancer yikes yeah okay either his brain
is so broken he accidentally told the
world he has cancer or the dude has
cancer or what if he has cancer and he
dies in the next year or two no no it's
okay because then we get president
president commonwealth but you get that
but i'm saying at that point in time
like how do you
not let the autopsy report go i mean
it's present united states you're not
going to release that and so then you
either lie about
how he died or it comes out that you
covered up that he really did have
cancer
and now you're sitting down here and was
like hold on well you knew he had it and
you lied that he had it
and now just again the public trust just
continues to erode and fall farther and
farther we have a very important quote
here from anarchist author michael malus
oh good who said don't worry about joe
biden having cancer he is married to a
doctor
referring to the fact that first lady
jill biden uses the honorific doctor to
note her 2007 doctorate in education i
love it i don't know if but i'm pretty
sure the education thing she has isn't
like a it's like it's not the same thing
as a phd or whatever i don't know it's
something else yeah yeah i don't know
what it is and i wanted to say i worked
with old people for the first 10 years
of my career and as you get older you
still can grasp some of these concepts
but you lose your filter and it just
comes out you just blurt it out and
that's i i liked it because i got to
actually know people because there was
no like you know not there's no um
pitter-patter they're not trying to
pretend there's something they're not
they'll just tell you exactly what they
think right up front i think that's what
he's doing here it's still crazy to me
though that the stuff that he gets a
pass for like i remember you know when
president bush the the son was in office
and he wasn't a great orator how many
people just decimated him when he had a
flub here or there and some of the stuff
that trump said how many people
ridiculed him for that but biden can
just say the most off the wall
outlandish stuff on planet earth and
it just gets swept on the road i'll say
though now dana carvey is making fun of
him on on kimmel did you see it
yeah he did like the oh trevor noted too
they're finally making fun of the way
biden talks his his weird man getting
real quiet and then getting real loud i
mean you should watch the dana carvey
skit maybe we can talk about on the
after show or go into it more or even on
this show if it comes up again but like
uh that's kind of like the tide has
turned people are like okay
we got what we needed out of them now
but the successor in the wings is no
better yeah i was gonna say for a long
time the white house refused to put out
his uh they kept saying he was gonna
have his annual health exam well it was
delayed something's going on and it went
on for such a long time to a certain
point it just seemed like they wanted us
to stop asking about it and
the other thing that's so strange about
his presence is how much time he spends
at his home in delaware i mean they
don't release the visitor logs for that
so we just don't know what goes on there
i mean it's total conspiracy for me to
say this but like if he is being treated
for something that's an easy place for
him to receive care in the privacy of
his own home good point
he's been retreating quite a bit i mean
i think it was something like
over 50 of the weekends that he was
president during his first year he
wasn't at the oval office he wasn't at
the white house i think the majority of
them were spent in delaware at one of
his two residents well were they doing
the i know they did a bunch of the
mock-ups of the fake like the fake oval
office when he was getting the shots and
stuff where were those at i don't know i
heard they were across the street in a
studio which is even weirder yeah yeah
what but i couldn't confirm that i don't
know where it was uh i keep thinking
about fdr frank and eleanor roosevelt
who had polio and he was like [ __ ]
because became crippling paralysis
started to affect him while he was in
office but he just lied to everyone
didn't didn't announce it and he put the
front panel on the desk at the oval
office that's why it's there to hide his
wheelchair i got a picture of him like
holding on to a metal railing while he's
tossed smiling and people didn't know
they didn't because it was we were i
guess the theory was we're at war we
don't want to freak out the public we
want to project strength which is like
the thing you talk about y'all were
talking about on the show the other day
about how aoc getting power but she
wants to do good to get there right well
that's the slippery slope that comes
with that like you can absolutely
justify why he lied about polio right is
the betterment for the country we don't
want to seem weak the whole nine yards
but at the same time
you just justified lying to the people
about the realities that they're facing
and it's it's just it's a bad slope to
go down
what do we do
i'm just like panic
we're facing two scenarios the president
is so demented he accidentally told the
world he had cancer
now
the united the enemies of the united
states
they're not sitting there going like but
does he have cancer they're going like
either way this dude is weak yeah and
now's our opportunity to destroy this
country do you think the cancer quote
has any change effect on that at all i
mean everybody looked at him like that
right as he is i mean he shook hands
with the air
twice couple times twice he did yeah i
wonder if maybe this is actually uh 40
chess from joe biden
make your enemies think you're weak when
you're strong yeah he read he read sun
tzu the art of war that's why he felt
him off the bike too that's right
it's a big ruse
he shows up to these meetings and
putin's like
the weak biden and then biden goes
listen here champ he's like i'm going to
tell you exactly what's going on and
putin's like oh no button is strong
when do you think he would announce that
he's not running for reelection soon
because they need to start getting ready
for the democratic primaries if that's
the case right yeah when would that when
do the primaries start getting announced
next year okay but but usually
you know like even right now with trump
the conversations are starting to pop up
of who is it going to be
we're starting to hear the same
conversations on the democrat side yeah
hillary clinton announced that i don't
know if his official but said that she
was going to run against trump was her
so that's true she didn't say that well
this is what i read on twitter i don't
know if it's all confirmed i didn't hear
out of her mouth either i thought they
were looking at ola newsom yeah
which is some which is nuts to me
it's nuts to me like the how he didn't
lose the recall is still i i don't grasp
that concept at all but as bad as
california is doing everybody leaves why
would that be your guy
just because it's a big state
you know
people aren't people are in a cult he
does look like he's i don't expect no he
looks like american society
he totally does yeah i think it's like
to contrast him with biden he's young he
has a young family like he looks healthy
i'm not saying i'm for a new run at all
i mean you just said he was attractive
two minutes ago
he's tall so he's got that over buddha
gig is it buddha judge is that how you
pronounce it boot edge edge booty gig
who i don't hate you know i don't hit i
don't really hate these people but like
buddha gay buddha jed sorry buddy
whatever you say he's smaller he's like
five nine i don't know how tall he's but
he looks little yeah and so they want
people like towering presents so i think
newsome has that going for him but biden
has the towering height you know as well
it's it's nuts man i don't see how i
still the thing that the biggest thing
that continuously shocks me about the
country is that you know you have these
people that are in office especially in
congress
for literally decades and they just keep
getting re-elected everybody knows
they're not worth two cents and we keep
catching them like you know gavin when
he was how many times was he in
restaurants
when it was shut down and he had his
mask off but then he just oh you know i
slipped i was taking photos and people
just forgive it and just go on i don't i
don't understand how that happened this
is a great great moral conversation
because like should leadership lie to
its subordinates that's the question
like in the military if they know
they're going into like a suicide or
mission where it's probably not going to
be very good do they tell the troops
that ahead of time or are they like
here's the mission you know um in my
experience you know if you're about
ready to go down a bad road like we know
it's a bad road you know you know that
it you're gonna get hit you know if
you're gonna run down ied alley you know
you're going down ied alley um i'm sure
there's probably at some point in time
we used to joke about it when i was in
like are they sending us on because i
had to go to the iranian border twice
because i did convoy escort and we're
like okay is this how we're gonna start
the war with iran they're gonna send us
out there's a sacrificial lambs to get
blown up and then we'll come back and
we're gonna be stopped so we would joke
about that but generally speaking my
experience has been like if you knew you
were about ready to get into it even
though the greatest oxymoron is military
intelligence they at least try to tell
you like hey like this is going to be
for real but with the president telling
the american citizens like hey here's
some strategy here's the that will get
leaked to the other humans around the
earth like your commander telling your
platoon something yeah the platoon is
not going to go tell the iraqi soldiers
what's happening so it's secure they
didn't take it a different step further
i mean a lot of times if something like
that is going to go down
i'll even give you another example of
that isn't necessarily like opsec but
like if a service member um got killed
they would actually shut down like the
internet lines and everything there so
you couldn't tell family back home until
the military had a time to tell the
family back home you know so they have
constraints on stuff along those lines
and again like back in war two loose
lips sink ships like that was a big
thing
but
when you look at this type stuff and
like whether or not he should tell the
world he has cancer right
you i think he should
you should know who's coming in next you
should know what's going on there
right and cancer isn't necessarily a
death sentence but at least we can
understand why you're shaking hands with
a glove laying in the corner i want to i
want to jump to this story it's the same
story from fox news but to make a
different point
fox news reports biden's cancer claim
shocks twitter users either the biggest
bombshell or biggest gaff i think it's a
fair assessment but i want to talk about
in relation to joe biden and donald
trump is this up here in the top right
the news guard certification
as of july 18th the daily beast has been
reinstated as true
real news
and fox news has been downrank
fascinating and so the reason is
they say that fox doesn't regularly
correct errors because there's a bunch
of stuff that tucker carlson's put out
that uh is factually incorrect and i
think newsguard is actually right about
that but there's an interesting question
in
outside of just fox news
in the presidency
let me show you this news guard says
while former president trump did claim
in a february 28 2021 fox news interview
that he requested that congress
authorized ten thousand national
guardsmen to bolster capital security
before january 6 there has been no
corroboration of this claim
why is it
that when there is something that is for
the narrative they can choose to ignore
the president
whenever whatever the narrative is they
will ignore if donald trump came out and
admitted to wrongdoing they would say
well trump confirmed it if donald trump
comes out and admits to something or
says something happened that would be
bad for their narrative they say it's
fake news
how does newsguard decide that the word
of the president of the united states is
not good enough to accept
meanwhile joe biden can come out and
says say he has cancer to the world
and it's also considered less than
credible now that's a very serious
problem if the president is outright and
overtly lying and the media just says oh
yeah we don't take the president's word
for it i can understand that you want
verification yet if you google search
biden confirms you'll see a bunch of
story about biden confirming the cost of
you know biden confirms unprecedented g7
move on putin set to cost billions how
do we know it's the president his words
meaningless we need
well biden's also said he has cancer why
should i believe anything
why should the media be allowed to claim
that biden's confirmed something
and then say oh but his cancer is not
true how many times has biden come out
and said something nonsensical and then
the white house has come out and said
actually what really happened is this
when donald trump says something they
say he's lying about it you can't trust
him
it's it's it's a nonsense reality where
the media decides when the president's
telling the truth
how does that make sense
my thing is i mean you guys you do the
journalist thing
i think the real question is when did it
stop did you have that ethical
basis of unbiased right i'm just going
to report the facts as they are like i'm
not going to tell i'm going to put any
any lenience on it like this is what he
said you make the decision whether or
not it is why does it have to have all
the other context behind it and we don't
do it either way you look at it like cnn
watchers don't get mad when cnn does it
but they get mad when fox does it and
vice versa
i still believe the problem in america
as much as we talk about the system it's
it's not it's not the system it's
americans
and i love the country i ran for office
i ran for office in frederick i ran for
county council at large i
ran actually the year
last governor race when the mood in the
country was significantly anti-trump and
democrats came out and drove iran as a
republican because in maryland you gotta
pick right
i knocked on over a hundred thousand
doors
do you know how many times i discussed
my platform
how many
one time huh one time ironically it was
a older man wearing a bernie sanders
shirt smoking weed in his retirement wow
we had a good 45 minute conversation
but i every door i knocked on it was
what are you running as and if i was
running what you wanted me to run as you
got my vote like you didn't even know
what i was you didn't no clue what i was
what my platform was
and
if i wasn't what you wanted me to be you
slam the door in my face and walk crazy
yeah well i think at one time in our
country your party affiliation was
shorthand for the things that you
believed in and your values not just
politically but culturally and that
shifted so much i mean the senator from
i'm forgetting his name right now from
oregon who just lost he's the first
incumbent
elected official from oregon to lose a
race since the 1980s he
said you know i'm a moderate democrat
and basically our party has been
controlled by socialists so it has moved
away from me i know that we hear
conservatives say this on many different
directions i mean you'll talk to
libertarians who say i don't feel the
way my parents felt socially i identify
fiscally as conservative but i'm
socially left i think that
we
are coming out of a day and age where
you could believe someone's political
affiliation
to be something of substance whereas now
you really do have to do the work to ask
someone and no one wants to do that
especially you know when you're suddenly
you know i think it's great that you
went door-to-door but like if you're you
have kids in the house you're doing
something else you don't want to be like
well how do you feel about this these
are the issues that import important to
me you want the shorthand you want to
say oh you've you're affiliated with my
team that's good enough and that just
doesn't really function in today's well
i mean the real rubber meets the road
and no one pays attention to this
is the local elections you know
everybody's hung up on congress and
president but hey if your property tax
is going up that's the county council
guy yeah right and when we went home
yeah and when we went to debates you
know and i'm running for the entire
county there were like 10 people in the
audience
and it's like you guys really
we're not involved and we have the
liberty honestly to not be involved
because for the most part people are
like well listen man like i'm doing okay
you know i'm commit i'm eating i'm not
worried about whether or not i'm going
to get mugged i'm not worried about
armed insurrection right now so
who really cares about tom that owns a
shoe shop that's running for county
council but that's who makes sure makes
and breaks your life really this is why
it always irks me a little bit when
people say you know vote for me for
congress and i'll clean up this town or
things of that nature and i'm like no
you won't you're going to go to dc and
represent there are you know us to them
if you want to clean up your your town
your neighbor you got to vote local and
the most important thing especially for
populists is voting local because you
know some people are in favor of a
convention of states some aren't but you
want to you want to set the rules you
want to change the laws in your state
maybe you're pro-choice maybe you're
pro-life that's your state reps you're
there the left might be wondering why
you know texas is banning abortion well
the state-level politicians the one who
do that not congress yeah but all anyone
ever talks about is national level stuff
it's a mistake the governor of new
hampshire really upset people when he
said he wasn't going to run for senate
he was going to stay in new hampshire
because he believed his work was he
could do more for the people of new
hampshire as governor than as senator
because the senator you end up spending
most of your time in washington i mean
if you it's it's not that there isn't a
place for both but i think being
involved locally is really
where you make a huge difference it's
unappreciated i think the real catch-22
is that i think
i'm willing to i really feel that 85 to
90 percent of people that go into
politics
honestly initially go into politics for
very very good reasons very honest
reasons ethical reasons they want to
make a difference the problem is the
longer you play that game the more you
become institutionalized with what it
takes to get something to actually be
accomplished i think a lot of people
lose sight of how complicated even a
state level bill is much less trying to
pass a law that's going to affect the
entire united states and that's why we
get these bills that are
ungodly links that have you know i'm
going to make something up at the time
you know
we want to pet puppies is thrown in with
hey let's give 20 billion dollars to
ukraine but we lead with let's pet
puppies right right and it's like one
paragraph of we had puppies and then 5
000 pages of how we're going to strip
money from the working class to fund a
war in ukraine but the problem the
headline is you know senator votes
against pet puppies yes yes yes every
time they do thomas massey a lot yeah
he'll be like i voted no on this little
like how could you vote no against
puppies and like because that provision
said we blow them up afterwards but then
no one wants to listen to that part
either that part's boring yeah it's
always bothered me that people get so
frustrated with federal politics i'm
like you need to look
at your next-door neighbor you need to
look at who's running for city council
who your mayor is going to be at who's
running your school board these are
important questions that affect you way
more than the present ever will honestly
and people don't want to put the work
and the federal government is there we
can complain about them it's not that
big a deal sure they taxes whatever but
for the most part they leave us alone
that tax though yeah oh i know but if
they if you actually do want to make a
positive difference in your culture you
need to run like you did or you need to
at least very least pay attention to
what's going on in your community part
of why national politics is easier to
get involved in this because it's
televised a lot of it's televised we see
watch c-span and crap like that but like
local politics isn't televised enough
for people to like because they don't
want to go to the meeting people just
don't want to they want to stay at home
and witness it from their tv if they can
i think it is but people people have
only watched national news so it's like
when you turn nowadays with the internet
you're not turning on your local news to
see a local like public access people
are turning on c-span for congress or
they're
pulling up cnn that only talks about the
fed or federal level i mean it's a
reality now
in broad generalizations like
in today's society and economy both
parents have to work
your kids are involved in 15 different
things so they're going right from piano
practice to football practice to ballet
practice they got a busier schedule than
most adults now and so these debates and
things they don't take place to 5 30 6
30 at night on a thursday afternoon well
that's little timmy soccer practice
what's the likelihood that i'm going to
come to that you know and that's where
you lose it is that like calvinism the
idea that if everyone's working they
can't do anything else
i could be mixing things up because a
sect of christianity
it could be um like puritanism maybe
there's like this idea of busy keep
everybody busy toiling the fields so
that they can't do anything else
if everybody has to work 24 7 they can
never revolt you don't have any trouble
i think is what the thought is
no one can get into mischief or be lazy
or do something like that if that's like
the road to kim jong-un's keep everyone
starving and then they won't revolt kind
of mentality but the other problem here
now we saw this in maryland and i i i
was going off about this today because i
still can't believe
they
push cox through in the primary
but
at every measurable thing that you can
look at just about maryland is
substantially better off than it was
before governor hogan took office and
because one or i hate the term rhino it
drives me nuts because anytime somebody
disagrees with one thing that a
republican said he's he or she is now
automatically a rhino and it's really
decimated a lot of times the republican
party in my opinion but they go in here
and they make this big push for them and
i'm like dude
you're never going to agree
with everything that everyone says i
guarantee you every one of us disagrees
on something at this table right but
what you have to look at is what is the
overall picture are we much better than
we were there and then at the same time
like i was arguing with the guys like
you know somebody just santa says like
desantis couldn't come here and win in
maryland and governor hogan couldn't
take maryland policy to florida and get
anything done it's two completely
different electorates and no one wants
to acknowledge that and it's like yo
like listen if if you love descent it's
that much in florida which i think i
went to daytona during bike week in
covet and they were having a blast move
to florida that's that's your solution
but if you're going to stay in maryland
what are what are your choices you got
your choices of having improvement where
he took us from like
i think 46th in
business in an economy to six over eight
years that's massive
why would you not be happy about it
let's i want to ask this question
because um i'm not sure if it was alex
jones or someone i think it might have
been alex implying that joe biden would
get sick and then they would replace him
or bring in kamala because joe biden
can't run so the question that we've
been asking right now
is joe biden going to run for another
term he says yes i don't know if i
believe it because you've got all these
democrats lining up you've even got
prominent democrats outright saying to
journalists
we don't think biden's going to run we
don't want them to run polls are showing
they don't want biden to run so how
could biden run against the will of the
democrat voters against the will of
other democrats and in the face of all
the democrats running against them but
if that's the case
how do you get biden out now
well some have suggested he'll be he'll
get sick or he is sick or something will
happen to his son i'm wondering what you
guys think about this you know just just
bouncing back to the cancer thing but
taking in this direction
could it be that this is meant to be
sort of just um
a little uh little little sprinkling of
the biden is very sick thing
so that
when finally the time comes i'll say you
know like uh
other presidents who have feigned
illness yes he's sick and he needs to
step down and kamala's moving in i think
no that it wasn't intentional only
because of their responses like no no he
meant he used to have it and and but i
think it is an indication that he's sick
and that they will pivot into that as it
comes up i think i'll actually run he'll
be on stage with other democrats that
are running and he'll be like you know
what you're right you're the one that
needs to take the torch and get like his
60 million followers to just clap and
smile and turn towards the next person
in line whoever means
i wonder if it's going to be opposite i
wonder if they're going to be like okay
joe so you're not going to run next
anymore so just just keep it cool and
he's going to be out somewhere and he's
like yeah so when i run for re-election
they're going to be like what do we do
because we don't actually want to
support this guy anymore but i think the
fact is joe biden's old he is sick i
don't know if he has cancer but imagine
what would happen pr wise for the
democrats if joe biden was on stage in a
debate and collapsed
that would be bad for biden but good for
democrats it's so funny that he said i
have cancer and you were like i don't
know if he has cancer like you just
don't know
like and anyone that came to me and told
me that i would believe them why would
you think they rely on you that's crazy
no it's crazy right why do you think it
would be good for democrats it would
create a whole lot of sympathy
it would give biden an exit which would
be honorable on honorable exit
uh they would say you know biden
sacrificed himself to stop trump that
kind of that kind of stuff or sacrificed
his health
they would ham it up they would say
here's a man who stepped out of
retirement after he lost his son knowing
he was sick because he knew america
needed a leader
and then you know he gets sick and maybe
he doesn't die maybe just collapses that
would that that's the perfect exit for
biden it's the perfect positive pr spin
so i'm not saying it will happen i don't
know it gives you kind of like a martyr
like heroic like exit
but i don't think they want camilla i
mean i think which i still don't
understand how she got the the nod as
the vp i i agree
but if
just because she steps up as vp doesn't
mean she runs in 2024 she could she'll
go out there and let's say
hypothetically joe biden faints you know
on stage or something at some kind of
town hall and they're like oh no and
then he's like i can't run you know the
american people you're going to need
someone younger
kamala steps in they remember when they
announced the 25th amendment panel and
everyone was like they're trying to get
trump out and then people like no no
it's for biden like they were preparing
to remove fighting yeah
so they did that
and a lot of people said that you know
that's what's going to happen it could
still happen
but i didn't get sick faints kamala
harris says i'm going to come in and i'm
going to take over as president
but i'm going to step aside and let
someone else run i'm not just sticking
correctly she does a lot of this motion
well you know i'll do my best
we the collective knowing what we know
we're going to do what we've always done
today
and i'm going to nominate gatin for be
president
i just i think she is i i still don't
understand like obviously the people
that put the stuff together have more
experience with it than i do but of all
the people you could have picked i mean
she wasn't even popular with what they
were going for on the base so
the dnc picks them yeah and they pick
biden and they're going to pick the next
one and they'll probably tell biden we
picked this person now just support them
or something like that kamala harris
check the right boxes i guess yep
diversity yeah diversity woman of color
diversity but you couldn't find anyone
else i mean like even
that's i'm a fan yeah
she doesn't she doesn't think inside
their box i mean tulsi gabbard is too
independent for them i i don't think i
think kamala harris knew this was her
shot she couldn't have run her president
i mean she wasn't going to get the
nomination on her own i gotta say you
know when we were talking about aoc she
went on colbert and she made up this
mishmash hodgepodge of civil war history
that was just hilariously brilliant and
uh
it was it was a chad move it was the the
ultimate chad move to go and just go on
national television and just make up
history and you got to think about
kamala harris you know when she does
these speeches that are considered auto
text like like you know predictive text
filler
that's also a chat move
she's going up on stage knowing she's
saying nothing and people clap for her
it's just like
the ultimate mockery of your own
constituents
and she just throws that cackle behind
it and it's just
like nails on the chalkboard it's the
worst thing
i mean she has incredibly low uh
approval ratings she's not popular at
all i don't know how she
but who do you pick though who do you
think if you could if you could right
now your choice you got you you gotta
you to go biden or you got to go her who
do you want run in the nation oh her
comma okay i'd rather have a predictive
text generation like a literal
predictive text generator than either of
them but you know joe here's my fear
with joe biden
he is i think he's corrupt
but he's brain damaged so he might be
like i want i want to get a shipment
into
iran and you're like
iran do you mean iraq what no and then
they're like i guess we're going to be
shipping iran a bunch of military
supplies the president said so and
you're like whoa dude i get he wanted to
make money off this illicit deal but
he's having a weapon so when when biden
accidentally said libya over and over
again i'm like imagine him in the
situation room like tell him to press
the button and they're bombing the wrong
country
at least kamala harris is corrupt but
she can speak properly you know what i
mean like they're both not all with it
but she's just
a little bit more
cognitively with it i mean honestly
that's the point i hadn't really thought
about is like you know you get your
finger on the on the button you're just
taking begging me to hit it and then i
say the wrong place well we'll check it
out it's you know kamala and biden are
both corrupt but kamala lives on this
planet and wants to keep living on this
planet joe biden too but his brain
doesn't work so you know biden might
accidentally blow us up kamala doesn't
want to ruin she doesn't want to kill
the peasants who supply her with slave
labor you know what i mean the question
is though for me
who do you think
pulls the strengths
like i don't believe there's some
reptilian like if you know you go back
all of a sudden you pull the mask off
there's a lizard person there
but at the same time it's like
for you to have that much control is it
one person is it a group of people how
do you get to be in the group of people
like who is actually the one filling out
his note card saying hey say this and
then also repeat line i mean it may just
be staffers
you know but that's scarier
that's like super scary i feel like
you'd want to take a critical look at
who is propping by and up because they
have so much influence right now
especially if he's not capable of like
saying no we're being like maybe i
shouldn't say that i mean this guy is
reading his stage directions the shadow
government is a 22 year old intern with
no governmental experience he's just
like um i guess biden should probably
say he doesn't want to blow up russia
he's in so deep
and my experience with those interns is
they're not really happy i mean i've
been down to the capital to testify for
stuff before and you know they literally
have which i've always thought it was
funny when they talk about minimum wage
and they've got a staffer that the door
literally opens into them in their
little office on the thing and they're
working 70 80 hours for like 12 bucks an
hour so he's mad he's angry and never
said you know what hey you know what i'm
gonna it's literally ron burgundy we're
gonna show him this time he's putting on
the prompter and the end of quote repeat
the line yep he's burgundy he's doing it
because he could say f you america
that's too heavy-handed it's too much
but it might catch that one
no he said repeat line repeat the line
that's that's bad crazy bad that's bad
it's wow
well that's america for you i guess this
is what the american people wanted huh
they voted idiocracy that's what apathy
gets
well i think it's a cult i think it's
the media i i i don't i think it's
epithelia for a lot of people they go
out and they just hit the d but i think
they were able to get a lot of people in
a cult
you know yeah oh yeah you asked why is
the media when at what point did the
media stop serving the the transparency
and start serving an agenda i my thought
the answer that is when we go to war
whenever the country goes to war the
media apparatus
rallies to start printing propaganda war
propaganda we really we went to war not
technically but in 2001 when we hit iraq
and then it's never stopped it's we're
still in this turmoil and now i guess
you could say we're out of iraq we're
still occupying or we're out of
afghanistan we're still occupying iraq
and now russia there's a war between the
ukraine and russia that the government
seems to want to be involved in what
blows my mind is the shift from 9 12.
because i took i took the first i
responded to the pentagon on the night
on the terrorist attacks and secured the
pentagon and then ultimately took the
first team in to start doing remains
removal
and when we would leave the pentagon to
go back to do shift changes you just see
everybody i mean honking the horn waving
the flag everybody unified
and in such a relatively short period of
time
we just become
just really two almost warring tribes
and like literally they've had people
say you know you might have to fight
your neighbor
right so
for me it's like
when did we make that major major shift
and was it just because the news went to
a 24-hour cycle and now they need to
sell commercial space or they're only
going to put the most device divisive
angry rhetoric up because it keeps
people engaged or is it something more
than that i think after the uh 9 11
there's a lot of muslim hate and that
created the tribes and this was like
christian muslim american and afghani
whatever and then it slowly morphed with
social media started finding out how
much more popular their clicks were when
you got angry but at some point
people
got turned against each other
republicans and democrats it was like
when trump got elected they used that as
a catalyst media apparatus but i don't
know if it's an external thing you know
it's not all american nbc news is not
all american all the time like there's
people involved in that that aren't
american
um i don't know i don't know that
there's necessarily a date but it was
like around 2012 or 2013.
that is social media and then when you
look at that side of the house where you
get the echo chambers where now your
algorithms only show you the exact same
people that believe exactly what you
believe and then you actually go like
hey
man
i'm super right and everybody backs me
up but because you don't have like you
don't have the
town halls the community engagement
anymore covet made it worse because
everybody was literally confined to
their house and so now we just become
further and further instead of i think
jordan peterson is the one that talks
about it is that people are inherently
born with a he calls them red and blue
like inherently a left world view and
inherently a right world view and up
until social media that was actually
good because you had to come together
and they had to have conversation and
compromise and so we actually kind of
got a little bit centrist in miller road
but now because we don't really have to
interact with each other in person that
often anymore and we have these echo
rooms on social media
like the divide is just huge and that's
what makes it scary for things like is
it possible for us to see something like
a civil war or something where we
actually have this big fight coming down
the pike i do think so let me jump to we
got we got a lot of stories we got to go
through but maybe the most important one
right now in this context is this story
from business insider
democrats spend over 1 million dollars
to boost dan cox the trump loyalist and
2020 election denier who just won the
gop primary for maryland governor
literal conspiracy
it's a literal conspiracy
the democrats have a scheme
to put money
into trump supporting candidates who
they then come out and say are an
existential threat
they are scheming to manipulate the
american people
freaking them out but funding it's it's
a false flag this is literally the
democrats engaging in a false flag this
is going look let's say the democrats
are right trump supporters are an
existential threat to this country
trump's candidates and maga candidates
they're funding them and propping them
up some are winning the primaries the
ideas will beat them in the primary and
if you don't and even if you do they
gain followers from you helping them
regardless they're not going to go away
so if the democrats are right it's a
threat they are literally funding it and
if the reality is they're not a threat
democrats are engaging in a false flag
operation on the american people via
politics to seize power
okay fine that's not a coup attempt
that's something dastardly at the very
least do you know who's warning them
against this mitt romney he's telling
them this is like stupid strategy you
shouldn't do this i believe hogan even
came out and said like we are yeah he
was saying we're having democratic
interference in our election i mean
hogan has called cox a uh uh q anon
whack job i believe is the quote he is
not a fan at all but he is also not
looking you know for a guy who's built
his reputation on being able to work
with democrats in a state he doesn't
want this organization coming in and
messing with maryland i mean they were
they were actively putting this out uh
you know kelly schultz had sent out
multiple email campaigns i'd got him say
like listen like this is what's
happening and for me i i was actually i
talked about it several times today like
i i am still
mind blown
and people you know they were talking
about like one of my friends was like
he's gonna put god and country back into
you know the the schools and i'm like no
he's not he's he's in maryland he's out
democrats outnumber you two to one and
the independents in maryland
aren't going to lean that far right in
my opinion maybe i'll be absolutely
crazy but the guy they're putting him up
against i don't know if you know
anything about wes moore
but wes moore won uh the top 40 under 40
very important people shaping the future
of maryland when i won it he wrote a
book called the other west moore
he's a i'm almost positive he's a combat
veteran but i know he's definitely a
veteran he
was from baltimore
went he's a
best-selling author you know his book is
interesting he's a handsome fella you
know tall and handsome don't bring that
up
he's gonna make one gaffe and then i'm
joe biden you know he's gonna
he in in baltimore and in maryland he's
gonna he's gonna chew dan cox up check
out the uh the new york times uh data 62
reporting from the democrat side and
they're already up about 140 000
uh votes so
you know look the question about whether
or not democrat maryland
goes republican i'm not super worried
about that
dan cox won by 16 points good for him
i don't see kelly schultz winning either
i mean the turn on the republican side
wasn't that high the bigger issue is
democrats
and their the schemes the manipulation
on the american people look did you
really think maryland regardless of this
would become a republican state i didn't
think he would become a republican state
i person this is and i i know kelly um
and maybe there's some bias there but i
genuinely think that she had an
opportunity coming behind hogan where
the state had improved as much as it had
and i believe she was a commerce
secretary or labor secretary one of the
two
and i thought she could get independence
and could and again with the sentiment
being as much against biden as it is
that she stands a very strong
probability at this year i literally
said if if you're gonna win this was the
year for you to win
right
i think she had a shot and still was
gonna be a fight dan cox
i'll do i'll owe you 20 push-ups i mean
i i i get that too
but she couldn't even muster it's like
if you can't get enough support from
your own party
i don't see how she could win look i i
i
if you can't convince republicans to
vote for you you think you'll convince
independents i suppose i just don't know
and i think maryland's a weird state for
republicans because basically all of one
side of it the the three western
counties want to leave they don't want
to be involved anymore they want to go
join
they sent letters to west virginia being
like please we'd like to go and west
virginia was like we'll have you just
you have to ask baltimore and baltimore
is like can't hear you stop asking that
i don't think they would do that because
then what would happen if there was all
of a sudden just a massive migration of
parts of states like they literally just
start swapping and changing they should
it's not a bad idea save the country in
my opinion the county state of jefferson
the county under um the eastern
panhandle in west virginia it's part of
virginia has winchester virginia in it
in its constitution if i'm remembering
correctly a west virginia state senator
told me this they have a bylaw in there
that
when west virginia seceded they left it
so if they decide later they're
frustrated with virginia they could
leave so that still stands they could
like file out and be like we don't want
to be here anymore that's not true for
the three counties in maryland but it is
interesting that there are these places
saying we don't look like where our
capitals are we are not represented by
our values we're in western maryland and
it is maga country you go to the grocery
store outside of frederick and brunswick
and it's like trump trump signs on you
everywhere and it gets more intense as
you keep driving through the panhandle
but you right but you go into frederick
and then the trump flags turn into
rainbow flags and what's crazy is about
that is and we were actually talking
about this earlier is like a republican
even when cause frederick flipped the
year that i ran it flipped blue right
and there was a big conversation about
whether or not it was going to stay that
way based on the migration from
montgomery county up
but what's what's crazy about it is why
does that happen in just the city like
everything else is absolutely red but
this little small city that we have
it instantly morphs to where it's
democrat
and then it's all people coming in
and what's crazy about it is people
leave moco because they don't like moko
and then they turn frederick into moko
people leave california and go to
austin because they didn't like
california but you turn austin into
california and it's like because they
don't they don't understand
they don't understand how they caused
the problem the snowflake doesn't blame
itself for the avalanche simply put joe
rogan moves from you know california to
texas like texas will be better and then
everyone says yeah but but i like joe's
opinions and then it's like but joe has
staff and joe has industry around him
and the industry is woke and left so if
joe rogan comes to austin sets up a
comedy club which he's doing he's going
to attract woke leftists from california
who aren't going to have those opinions
he's going to attract their sound
producers and their stage managers and
their taxi drivers and their restaurant
tours and then
texas turns democrat kind of
colonization
yeah kind of feels like they're
colonizing but to be fair
there is a cultural influx in a texas
which is actually turning it fairly
purplish like purple leaning red and i'm
hearing like in austin
it's it's it's like kind of kind of blue
but people there are fairly anti-woke
which is surprising not completely but
i'm hearing i'm hearing that at least
from a lot of people and what i'm
hearing from some of our friends who
moved austin it's because they're moving
there so maybe it is a good thing me i
like west virginia because it's already
like the second most trump supporting
state in the country with like 86
percent trump support
not the entire state every county went
red
yeah i mean i i don't i'm not saying
trump is a god emperor or anything like
that but i would rather be surrounded by
people who will leave me alone than
people who won't simply put i like west
virginia because it's culturally purple
like it was such a blue state for such a
long time and it's changed to being read
now i mean i think it is i said this
before but it's a murder of the fact
that the parties are changing but the
people's values aren't necessarily
they're not being interpreted or
projected by the parties the way they
were back in the day
and i i don't know i think that
you'll see that there are states that
turn blue because of migration but
you'll see states that turn purple
because
they're not represented equally by the
two-party system good point you were
saying earlier danny that you thought
that like uh
that that um
oh i think i
lost my thought there oh that rhino you
don't like the term rhino dino you know
republican in him only and what you're
saying hannah claire is like that the
people aren't being represented by the
party there's too many disparate ideas
to represent have one party represent
them there should be lots of different
parties at this state at this point i
think because people are are rhinos
they're they say the republican because
it's one or the other you got to pick
one but your identity is not it doesn't
fall in line with them well there used
to be the term like blue blood democrat
right which was a blue dog democrat or
whatever it is but like it's like back
then like you were like kind of how i
look at myself like i don't want you
spending my money you know what i'm
saying i don't want you in my life but i
don't care what you do in your life like
knock yourself out it doesn't bother me
at all like if you want to hug trees hug
trees i'm cool with that but that's gone
now and what i can't understand is how
the parties continuously switch back and
forth as to who's who you guys were
talking about the other day where like
now the now the republican party's
becoming like the blue collar
working in person right where that was
the democrats for a long time like his
blue collar unions the whole nine yards
so i i mean one point time democrats had
the kkk you know what when were we how
do you how does that switch happen i
don't think it ever switched
really yeah i don't yeah i don't think
so
uh
there's there's a whole bunch of
articles and many have written their
thesis on how the parties which never
happened but i think if you look at the
democrats today and you look at the
democrats in the 50s and go back you're
like their policies had this similar
results across the board
it was just
i mean it is what it is well they say
places like baltimore like how do you
blame republicans and democrats have
been in charge there for what and
chicago and how do you blame uh the
right for police brutality or
you know
they march in new york city but they
keep voting for these people to keep
doing it then protest the people they're
voting for they talk about racist cops
yo you live in a democrat stronghold in
new york where democrats are appointing
the racists yeah so i'm like it's not
changed it's the same thing they just
need the pr push to claim it did
i look at the policies democrats are
acting look at this california they
tried to repeal their civil rights
provision from their state constitution
that's the democrats for you you know
it's funny right now
i was like i was trolling on twitter and
i put something like
someone commented about
abortion
and um denial of personhood rights and i
said yeah well you know who else wanted
to deny personhood rights and i was
going to put the confederacy and then i
was like
that was also the democrats and i was
like oh wait
the democrats back then denied personal
they denied today you know look you want
you want to issue a moral statement on
abortion fine that's what i'm saying i'm
saying the left is inherently of
opposing personhood rights for the
unborn
it was the democratic party that opposed
personhood rights for slaves
the republicans wanted civil rights and
constitutional rights for everybody so
you think the democrats just
for literally the entire time with the
united states just have a better pr team
well i don't know about a better pr team
i think they had a worse pr team in the
civil war everyone that you had you had
to think what
almost three times as many union
soldiers fighting against them yeah so
uh i think maybe later on they started
to figure out maybe in the past several
decades they learned control of
institutions was power they needed to
seize it you know i take a look at a lot
of the
you know we talked a bit about this the
other day you take a look at
aoc pretending to be handcuffed
and it's just like manipulation for
power oh she actually said something
about that said that if it's just safer
yeah you're supposed to keep them down
and back because otherwise if your arms
are flailing they might say that you're
resisting arrest oh come on i really
wanted the headline on our site to be
aoc poses in handcuffs in front of
capital because it was just like such a
moment she clearly decided that was the
way it was supposed to be but is
anything less impressive than getting
being a congress person getting arrested
where there's absolutely no real
repercussion against you like
catch and release yeah did she face any
backlash for that from people being like
there are people who are arrested who
don't have the ability to get out of
jail the way you would you know
i wouldn't be surprised if the vote
comes for its own being like your
privilege that's why you got out of jail
yeah whatever then she'd be like but i'm
fighting for you and it's like
look
it is it is undeniable that you have
many democrats today who will publicly
scream racism is bad whereas you had
democrats in the past who would scream
that segregation was good like the
problem is democrats saying racism is
bad is just a mask for them saying
segregation is good democrats are
outright the party of segregation today
and they've always been that's why i'm
like i don't know where that parties
which supposedly happened you can say it
was the 50s or whatever but when you go
to seattle or portland you see the
libraries and they have poc and non-poc
rooms you're like yeah it ain't the
republicans who are calling for that
it's the democrats once again
wasn't there a college where a bunch of
or a group of students of color had been
like we want our own dorm we should be
like allowed to have our own space and
it you were thinking like but i thought
this is segregation i thought we had
fought against this they do that
they i was reading someone's article
about how they have like asian dorms and
black dorms i think it's like you see
the uc system in california university
of california system
and and the answer i think they gave i
could be wrong was like people want this
and i'm like you know
i guess
it doesn't mean you you
make it you know what i mean if if you
know if people choose to live next to
each other i guess there's not really
much you can say if people are looking
for a dorm and you're like that's the
norm for your race that's the dorm for
their race it's like that's a that's a
bad idea you should not do that i just
thought it was weird because it's these
institutions that like charge you a
bunch of money to live like this far
away like one arm's length away from the
other person their rooms are so small
you can touch your roommate's bed and
then they're like no but but if people
want to live by race it's fine like they
don't actually care about how people
live how crazy about the money i
remember hanging out at the columbia
dorms in chicago and it's a two bedroom
with i think eight or maybe it was four
or eight people i'm not sure i think it
was four people each room had two bunk
beds in it or had a bunk bed in it for
two beds and they were like it's a
thousand bucks a month to live here and
then i was like you live with three
other people and you spend a thousand
dollars a month why don't y'all just
like i don't know buy a house you got
four grand per month you can go buy a
house not that far away from here and
they're like i don't know well colleges
make it a requirement to live on campus
so that first year they're charging you
and you have to buy whatever the biggest
like food or meal package or whatever
else so they're guaranteeing money i
mean they are not in it for your
personal growth they're in it for their
bottom line college is a scam yep yeah
do they actually make people live on
campus there were people that would
commute on when i was going i i think
different schools do it different ways
but a lot of schools the first year
first two you're required to live on
campus like a status school where it's
like cool for you to be part of it so
they want to make you have to be you
have to agree to it like your community
college no one cares that you're going
you can commute all you want do they
like market it to like families it's
like oh so your student can get adjusted
and be acclimated and like get used to
living away from home like it's a safety
net like they're going to kind of
babysit your kid for you that is cultish
beyond measure i didn't know they were
forcing kids to go stay there with them
while they indoctrinate them i thought
that people could still commute
it's just the first two years when
you're the most vulnerable to a doctor
well okay let's let's get good news
good news for everybody
so you can you can have some optimism
and hope for your day
federal probe into hunter biden has
reached a critical juncture and
investigators are weighing possible
charges
so i don't know crack your beers yes
order your pizzas get your wings have a
celebration kick back
nothing's happened yet but maybe hunter
biden will actually be charged for being
a criminal do you guys think that's
actually gonna happen no
no
but it's like
sprinkling a little bit of hope in front
of us it's so nice like maybe there's
going to be some accountability i think
what would happen even if he was right i
mean everybody's seen all the i mean we
literally have video footage you know
it's kind of like that old feel better
you know it's kind of like that old joke
where they're like how would you what
would i think dave chappelle's one they
did he was like how would you agree that
it was uh r kelly actually did it i'd
have to have a video of his grandma
pointing at him going that's my baby
like there's countless videos of him
doing co doing coke crack
weapons
strippers the the weighing meth video
was like the funniest where he's like
he's arguing with the hooker about how
much meth he's got on his scale is that
math or crack i've heard both did you
ever uh
like it was a big scandal because they
were like buying alcohol
now we have like hunter biden who's like
with his hookers weighing his mess like
what a country what a time she's like
that's
he goes it's 20.6 oh okay like she's
trying to rip him off i got i mean you
got a charge yeah she's a negotiator do
you see the was it the babylon b that
wrote inflation is so bad you could only
buy
yeah 20 you know i was like you only buy
2.6 grams of crack from what you used to
be able to buy 20.6 or whatever
yeah i mean if you get if it gets
charged it gives me a you know i go from
having no faith in the government to
having like 0.1 yeah really will he
throw his child under the bus to
to re-negotiate faith i think this must
be a crazy time to be his kids i think
one of his daughters is getting married
they're going to host her reception at
the white house like meanwhile while
she's planning that we have like her
dad's hooker and meth photos questions
yeah one of hunter's daughters is
supposed to be getting married i think i
think it's one of the biting
granddaughters who's gonna have her
reception at the white house i assume
soon before he has to maybe leave office
uh but i think it's one of hunter's
daughters and i just think like
man that's your dad do you invite dad is
he alive to come to the wedding i don't
know definitely invite him video chat
careful you know like if you're hunter
just word of the wise a word word from
the wise hunter make sure your dad
doesn't sniff your daughter
does he get to bring a date is the
question
allegedly he must allegedly hunter calls
his dad a pedo
really
so it's allegedly yeah yeah
leaked texts he refers to his dad as
peter peto peter
which is honestly like if you think
about it like that then you almost kind
of have to have like he almost becomes a
sympathetic figure like is he that
messed up because
you know i think joe biden abused hunter
oh for sure like how do you get a guy
raising a family that wealthy to turn
out the way he did with hookers and all
these drugs because his his dad
gropes and sniffs little kids publicly
what does he do with him in private he's
probably vacant a lot too being a
politician
working on the hill like he was always
away at work
this his son his his son's mom and
sister had died in the car accident when
he was like two when hunter was two he's
in the car with them so he lost his mom
he lost his sister his brother actually
died uh beau biden from cancer a while
back like a decade ago or something so
hunter i mean what a broken environment
just from an uh
top-down observation looking at that
family yeah now then you add the
personal stuff that he actually calls
his dad allegedly peto peter you don't
just joke around about your parents
being pedophiles
i don't know people that joke around
about their parents being pedophile i've
never met somebody like that no i was
not joking yeah i was thought it was
weird that during i think it was it must
have been the 2020 uh democratic
national convention that they
were highlighting all of his
granddaughters really intensely and then
all of a sudden they're like and his one
grandson they're like we talk to grandpa
every day and like we do this and like
you know i obviously hope they have a
very positive and healthy relationship
with whoever in their lives but like
they really really focused on these
girls
ignoring the fact that he had two sons
they didn't really talk about any of his
actual kids it's like they needed a
fresh face because maybe everyone else
like couldn't manage to swing a positive
statement about biden it was just weird
you're talking about
hunter's daughters or joe's so he has
like
five grandchildren i think and i think
it's uh or maybe four but it's like two
girls from beau's marriage and then a
boy and a girl from hunter's marriage
tara reid complaints where she said he
pushed her up against the wall and just
basically a sexually assaulted her in
one of the cap in one of the buildings
over there on at the capitol and like
the way he grabs women and i'm talking
about joe biden has on video like
grabbed women and smelled them and
sometimes you see the girls recoil like
that one redhead girl was like recoiling
from it i mean very overtly like
making that face like what is he doing
kind of face and you can hear him going
like give me some of that sugar that's
so nasty it's so just i mean that hard
grab you know i mean that's like an old
1950s
smacker when she's like if she's if
you're angry it kind of
come on man
you gotta give her a firm open palm
smack on the bottom the tara read stuff
has to be investigated i mean it was so
what her claims are so damning about
what he did to her i mean dude look at
the guy there's websites dedicated to
showing him sniffing and groping and
debut just like it's it's it's abusive
to children you know
truly literally what that girl was going
through when that red hat was that was
like a form of abuse remember when joe
biden would say
that you know i'd be at the pool and the
kids would touch my hairy legs i got
hairy legs remember that stuff yeah
someone made a meme and they said uh
what if corn pop
actually was just a dude who saw biden
creeping on children and called him out
what's the corn pop story joe biden said
he saw a guy get up on a diving board or
he was running or something he said hey
esther stop running and the guy was like
what did you call me and he called
esther williams or something so the corn
pop guy you know had a hit a razor blade
you put in a rain barrel get it all
rusty you know
and then joe you know some guy told him
get a chain and fight him and then joe
said i apologize calling you asked her
man i shouldn't have done that and the
guy backed off it was a story he told at
the pool and a bunch of people were like
you know what makes more sense is that
a young ish a young man joe biden
was creeping on children because he's
he's you know a creepo and this dude saw
him and was like yo get out what the you
know what i mean
i mean biden told the story like the
kids would grab his legs
it's a creepy story anyway i gotta hurry
legs the kids would grab my legs and
they would rub them and the hairs would
go straight that's what he said
i think corn pop may have been like you
leave those kids alone man
shout outs corn pop shout out yeah what
if corn pop was the good guy he was the
hero we needed the twist that's the
twist
that's a twist we need i mean i think
joe biden's an abusive guy i think he's
a corrupt guy i think he's crooked
across the board and it wouldn't
surprise me if this whole sick thing is
an act so that people think he's a
bumbling idiot when he's actually just
gut in the country regarding this story
about hunter biden possible charges what
are these possible charges for
tax false tax violations or making false
statements when buying a gun
he would have been prohibited from
purchasing a gun because he admitted he
has a drug problem and that's what
everybody was calling out like
you you care about gun control start
with a resting hunter biden who lied in
his gun form
we all saw it and then he threw the gun
in a dumpster no it was
his wife somebody threw it in a dumpster
throwing a dumpster next to a school
yeah what the heck
well that's always been the issue with
when people scream for gun control like
you've got you've got
gun control in place everywhere now you
just don't actually enforce it
so what's another rule what's another
law it's not going to do anything
but now that i mean i didn't know the
thing about the pedo thing i was i was
sexually abused as a kid and so like
that has a you know that has a
relatively profound effect on you for
the rest of your life and now like now
you made me feel so bad for the guy i'm
like man
lord what if he really does have all
that issue and he's just been the
scapegoat for this the whole time yeah
hunter biden was probably abused by his
dad i mean i do think though that like
people
who suffer horrible things as kids still
have some responsibility for the damage
they cause as an adult i absolutely
agree with that i'm a big person for
personal accountability
but at the same time like for me it was
like family members that did it to me
but they weren't
setting congressmen you know there's a
there's also like a level of
i don't know if you're at that position
or you're president like i've met a
couple presidents and like
it's weird like you get an it's almost
like a presence about them and so you
add on top of the fact that they're your
dad that oh yeah they're one of the most
powerful men in the country too
like what could he have got that guy to
do you know what if he was just a
scapegoat what if it was more than just
uh he was you know sexually abusing him
with the mental side of it you know what
you're going to do this you're going to
do this i'm going to actually put you
out as a pawn so if anything bad happens
it's happening to you it's not happening
to me but i'm still going to reap the
benefit of all the deals that you make
i've heard that jill and hunter also do
not get along at all jill joe's current
wife at
you know his hunter's stepmom basically
now this is hypothetically just resents
hunter because not only does he remind
jill of his his mother joe's first wife
and probably love of his life or
something but like hunter's a
a screw-up and so he's putting a bad
name out there so she's like oh and he's
hurting joe's reputation i can't you
know so but in the text he's like really
vicious against her as well which i
imagine is another layer of stress
family stress personal stress
i have sympathy for him but i don't
doesn't condone the behavior yeah i mean
i can sympathize with like victimhood
but nothing that he's done you know like
look he's an adult man who has done
really messed up things that's that's
that's that's not him it's a lot of it's
too is non-violent so that's you gotta
take that into account too like oh
possession charges you know prostitution
drug charges like no one's dying if
people have been shown up dead oh i was
talking about his illicit business
dealings with foreign that's actually
way a bigger deal than the coke or the
drugs in my opinion well maybe that's
why they go for the gun thing or this
type of charge here because we can say
we convict you on something or we can we
can go there but we're actually going to
ignore the really bad things that you
did
they distract from the bigger issues and
the illicit business dealings by lock
you know give and they'll give them a
slap on the wrist it'll be like well
it's your first time and you know you're
going to get a year probation or
something yeah well they stand by
there's a bunch of kid like there are
young children i mean they're in their
20s or teens now but like
remember that hunter had an affair with
bo like he was married and then he had
an affair with bo's widow like there are
your actions have tons of consequences
there are people who you brought into
this world who did not choose to be the
grandchild of a politician to be the the
daughters and sons of like a guy who
is you know i i want to be empathetic to
what he might be struggling with but at
the same time like
this guy
is
destructive and he takes people down
with him it seems like especially people
who don't really deserve it yeah yeah
he's just filming but he's really good
at weighing meth so it's it's almost
like there's that uh james o'keefe meme
where
it's it's like a guy meets a hot girl
and immediately just says to her like so
let me tell you about the all the
corporate malfeasance i'm involved in
yeah and you wonder why it is like james
gets these guys on camera like why are
you telling them about these things you
do at your job that's wrong it's so
weird
and hunter biden's like an inverse of
that where he's like i'm doing something
illegal but i get my camera what the
heck i better film it put it on my phone
that's loud in my laptop it feels like a
self-destructive streak like i'm trying
i keep like
i you know i want to i want to make
atonement right maybe he has a
conversation with jesus every night and
he's like i'm really messing this up so
i'm i'm trying to get what's supposed to
come to me but they just won't arrest me
no matter what i send them yeah leaving
the laptop like he did that you could
argue maybe he was drug-raddled and
forgot it but that feels like
self-hatred and like he wants to take
down joe and he wants to expose it all
but doesn't have the strength feels like
he can't overtly do it so he'd make it
seem like or maybe he just knows
nothing's going to happen to him and
it's like flaunting it in your face i'm
going to do whatever i want you can't do
anything about it i'm protected by dad
and we just can call it a day i think
drug addle makes sense
but he probably walked in and he was
like
he might have forgot that he left it
there but but drugs most well actually i
don't know i can't speak for all drugs
so i don't know if he was doing crap
yeah he was probably wired
yeah i don't know he probably took that
whole computer apart and rebuilt it
himself maybe biden's kids are just very
forgetful i mean he leaves laptop ashley
leaves her diary like they just are not
good at keeping track of their
belongings yeah it's just a stutter they
record everything he just stuttered no
i'm just kidding that was a that's a joe
biden meme it's not just a stutter by
the way let's jump to this uh very
timpool-esque story from the daily mail
half of americans expect a second civil
war within years more than 40 percent
agree with great replacement theory and
nearly a fifth expect they will choose
to bring a gun to a violent political
what
alarming poll shows how do you poll that
that's both call a thousand people and
be like do you plan on bringing a gun to
a political event like yes i do okay
indeed i do i recommend against that
half of americans expect to see a second
civil war within years and nearly a
fifth
say they could one day be toting guns at
a political face off themselves
researchers at the university of
california davis uncovered worrying
levels of alienation mistrust and a
growing tendency to turn violence in
their recently conducted survey of eight
thousand six hundred and twenty adults
that's a huge sample size how many yeah
eight thousand six hundred and twenty
that's like four times what's considered
a good number let me tell you why i
think it's worse than people realize
because when i call when i'm talking to
a lawyer they say pick your jurisdiction
based on which president appointed them
and i'm like okay that's not a tenable
circumstance you can't have
a country where this this district judge
is abiding this one's trump so what's
your case for and against okay then go
to the trump one
if it's it's like that juror
and the bannon thing is that i don't
care what he says because of who he
affiliates with it doesn't matter if
you're a conservative and you're in dc
under on trial locked up
if you're if you're a liberal on trial
now you're fine they'll release you
what's the great replacement thing
they're talking about
it depends on depends on who you ask but
there's it's basically that immigration
is displacing uh natural born americans
and then
there's the white nationalist version so
like the left will say it's always the
idea that white people are being
displaced by brown people but many
people who are talking about immigration
might just say it's
natural born citizens being replaced by
yeah
i think the argument on the from the
left you know is that over time people
of color will
will will get married to and have
children with people of not color if
that's what the point we're all color
but like whatever the people of
european ancestry will get with people
from south america or whatever and then
their children will be mixed that's that
kind of replacement not that someone's
going to come in from south america and
then you're going to be unemployed and
no longer be participating in society
that's the white nationalist fear of
replacement i think it could be both
both known what's going to happen what
they're saying is that the white
population is decreasing the white
nationalist version and then minority
populations are increasing the general
idea is just democrats have publicly
stated immigration is a path to
political power for them and it's it's
simple leftists don't have kids they're
more likely to abort and sterilize so
how do they compete with conservatives
who have lots of kids immigration
education but here's a question yes and
a doctrine
for people that say
for people that say there's there's a
civil war
who's leading
how's it split
right
like we don't have the same
you know we don't have north versus
south in this country
was that what countries did most civil
wars don't function that way most civil
wars are like
random factions all over the place that
eventually coalesce when fighting starts
so the u.s is unique in that you had a
union of states break apart and then the
union was like you can't break apart
invaded the south the south you know
teams up or whatever joins forces most
civil wars are like a random faction
with a weird name starts fighting in one
area against the government then other
factions pop up then eventually groups
coalesce and then they're fighting each
other you take a look at like in syria
you had 12 different factions emerge
under isis you know
so one scenario could be
with the united states it very well
could be
state versus state it could be like the
old civil war
the the scenario that we talked about
quite a bit over the past week is
what happens if
a man and a woman you know get together
and the woman gets pregnant in texas
where it's illegal to abort yeah and
then at eight months the woman decides
to go to colorado to abort and the
husband or the husband or boyfriend or
whatever is like i will not allow you to
kill my child
now you're gonna have a very serious
conflict because there's no federal
statute and both states are completely
on the other end one saying it's it's
you're killing a child the other saying
no we're not and we're allowed to do it
one thing it's illegal you're saying
it's not
what happens
is is is are is the is the guy just
going to sit back guess my my own board
child dies in violation of the law or
are people going to fight
you know there's actually forget who it
is if you haven't seen it there's
actually a i think they did it at the
army war college they did a scenario of
what would happen if america fought
against itself and how the states would
go texas won in their uh in their deal
but
for me it's like with everybody shifting
do you
to wherever they're going like blues
moving to red does it ever just get to a
point where it's like okay well i don't
really care that much because
you're not overtly affecting texas
you know what i'm saying like you go to
where you want to live essentially
federalism right and now we're not we're
not
it doesn't really bother me what
happened in maryland doesn't bother me
because i'm in texas or vice versa do
you think that's a stopping point before
it and keeps that from happening do you
think that exacerbates it i i think it
might
be better in the long run federalism and
we talked about this when we had the
progressive feller on talking about
abortion and i was like i don't know
maybe it's better that we do overturn
roe v wade so that the states
who want to live the way they want to
live can and other states
can have their abortion texas can can
ban it but i just don't think the idea
ideology stops there
i don't think someone who truly believes
abortion is murder can sit back and let
people murder babies
and
i don't think the left has a strong
position on abortion at all they're just
tribally for it so that's why i don't
see the left as like
possibly going to invade texas to make
abortion happen they might secretly do
it maybe there's money involved but i do
see it as texas or some other state that
bans abortion as being willing to send
people or even unofficially to stop
abortion right do you take a look at the
first civil war john brown just took it
apart amongst himself what were the
factions there was one country john
brown went started shooting slave owners
in the face
it didn't matter that there was not an
organized faction it happened when the
fighting broke out then organized
factions emerged
so maybe that happens there's a fair
point maybe you get uh you're going to
see texas and they're going to be like
here's our annual report
3786 unborn children were were aborted
in a neighboring state and they're going
to be okay this has to stop because we
are morally opposed to the to abortion
and the other state says we're allowed
to do it you can't do anything about it
how long until a new john brown emerges
we've already had violence at abortion
clinics and and vice versa with the left
firebombing pregnancy centers but how
long now with the current situation
until you get a john brown and a
bleeding kansas where he goes into
colorado and just starts getting violent
or something big dif i think the big
difference between abortion and slavery
they're similar but is that slavery's in
plain sight but abortion is like out of
sight out of mind
because when i hear when you see the
ultrasound women they become way less
likely to want to kill the thing
i know that sounds crass but just get
past that part um and so
you just don't see it and it's like if
you don't see the sewage the sewage
isn't that big of a problem
um
slavery man that drove people insane
people went nuts over that well again
and i would now too i don't like it it's
also the issue though where i can see
what you're saying happens is the fact
that aoc it's it's legal where she is
right and who she represents
but then she's still going out there and
making this plea for the case for it to
affect states that are outside of her
jurisdiction and i i mean now that you
break it down that way that's an
explanation for like okay this is why
it's crossing the line because you're
trying to make it happen at a federal
level what we can do at a state level
well let me ask you again how do you
feel about abortion what's your thoughts
on it i don't like it man i don't like
it at all um but do you think it should
be legal do you yeah
so
i'll present present to you this way
when slavery was happening i'm sure
a lot of people said exactly what you
said i don't like it but you know it's
it's legal in those states that's a good
point and then what happens after the
war after the war they're like you
supported them you were defending them
you weren't speaking out
history is written by the victors and
that's why the left likes to say you're
on the wrong side of history because
they firmly believe that when the
fighting's done or whatever they'll be
they'll be the victors
i don't i don't agree with that at all
uh history has a tendency towards the
the expansion of personhood rights so i
don't understand why this would be the
the anomaly here in terms of
well this one time we've decided on you
know these these
unique individuals with dna are not to
be granted personal rights circumstances
are different you know with slavery a
person like human being living and
walking
with abortion they're still dependent to
a certain degree on the mother's body
but that's where viability comes in if
the baby is viable outside the womb this
is the big question
someone in texas a woman can take a
viable child
let's say let's say like the scenario
the man and the woman they get they hook
up they're together at eight months
lemon says i don't want to be with this
guy if i have this kid i'm trapped i'm
gonna go get an abortion the guy says
you don't need to kill it we can do it
we can we can do a induced labor or
c-section right now the baby is viable
and healthy and doesn't need your body
to live and she goes don't care i'm
going to kill it
that's where the moral line is drawn not
in like the first week where she
realizes she's pregnant and it's a you
know it's a zygote or whatever and it's
not viable we're talking about a woman
who could say
i could have this baby delivered
but then i'd be responsible for it so
i'd rather flee to colorado to kill it
now you're in
crazy territory see my problem with
everything has also always been the
hypocrisy of it meaning that
if somebody were to murder a pregnant
woman
they're getting charged
with
two counts of murder
so
for me i'm like
i just want everything to be equal right
like well if what the rule is the rule
is the rule so if it's if it's two
murder if i kill a pregnant woman then
we have then we're saying that the baby
is alive
you can't now turn around you're gonna
put that man or that person in prison
for the rest of their life based on two
counts of murder that was california
right was that yeah peterson yeah but
then you turn around and then when it's
abortion well it's not a life so
how can you do that that's the part that
has always it's always like not set well
that's why i think the
let's just call it the pro-abortion
post-viability side the pro-abortion
side i think they're gonna lose i think
it is a fair assessment to say based on
where history where we've come from and
where we're going that
50 years from now people will look back
on abortion the way they looked at it uh
look at slavery but you know what my
issue is i'm actually curious what you
think on this this is the problem that i
had with the overturning of it
is
you know
that branch is supposed to be
independent of political party right
but it absolutely is 100 you guys talked
about this before like they want to now
stack
the they want to stack it because they
can't get their policies through
it's still frightening to me that based
on who you put
in those chairs we can have a complete
180
of an interpretation of the foundational
law of the land
simply based on the partisan views of
the person that's supposed to be in the
job so that's that's that's you agreeing
with the supreme court the supreme court
clarence thomas particularly wrote they
keep doing this thing called was it
substantive due process or something
like that this idea that there are some
things that are just so so uh egregious
or whatever that no amount of due
process would would be uh adequate to
deal with the situation that is to say
they're like
the courts should not be allowed to deny
this to a person because they're a
person and it's like
what the supreme court is saying now is
congress
codify it the supreme court does not
decide this
what what so from your perspective
and i i agree with what you're saying
the supreme court should have never
decided to legislate from the bench
correct here's a challenge though the
country is too divided to actually move
forward on a lot of issues now they just
recently uh in the house codified gay
marriage and it's very likely the senate
will support it excellent i don't know
if they've ever done that with
interracial marriage either though but
there's a bunch of issues the supreme
court effectively forces through without
the will of the people without the the
electorate which is kind of crazy when
you think about it the supreme court
today said we don't have the authority
to do that clarence thomas went on to
say we should revisit these other cases
to also correct these errors and oh so
what he was essentially saying there was
that we should put this back to the
legislator to make the decision on it we
don't have the authority or capacity to
actually rule on it but how people
reacted was he's trying to end
the truth of the matter is no one's i
mean in my case no one explained it like
that
yeah you know and that's what we talked
about earlier is like everything's a two
second sound bite so you don't ever
actually get any context behind anything
anymore which is why it's also so damn
easy to get everybody riled up and angry
about what's going on i'd love to to
know how many people think that the
supreme court just made abortion illegal
oh yeah an insane amount
that's wild and insane well and then i
would have people say to me like well
when you like this means that when women
who have a stillborn baby aren't going
to be able to get treated because
it's it's not considered an abortion
when you have a stillborn baby and
you're too far along and the baby is
surgically removed from your body like
that's tragic that's sad but like it's
not actually an abortion and no one
thought it was an abortion until we
suddenly decided that the supreme court
had taken abortion away from everyone uh
i think there was a such an intense
panic i mean i really want to know how
much planned parenthood fundraised in
the last month because
everyone panicked and was like we have
to figure out how to protect this right
which like
i i just think that
so much got lost in translation and if
you really believe that abortion is you
know a right that you need to have i
respect that like i don't have to agree
with you but i think so many
outlets and so many people did a
disservice to everyone around them by
just panicking and encouraging people to
panic and well they use the most extreme
they use but listen both sides are
guilty of this they use the most extreme
case of whatever it is to justify
whatever point it is that they're trying
to make right
and for example when the people that
were very uh pro-abortion are like
they're gonna make your rape daughter
give birth
right and i got two i got i'm a girl dad
i got two daughters and
that's that's touches a nerve you know
what i'm saying but that's what we lead
with when the reality is
that's a very small exception to the
rule and in in my knowledge of i can't
wouldn't go put my hand on the bible on
this but in my knowledge
in most cases in most states
even with even when it's banned that's
permitted like
this happened like no you don't have to
do it so people make that because they
get everybody riled up over it and it's
just super super easy and nobody ever
steps back and goes okay well what is
the actual reality of this how often
does it happen what are the
circumstances for it to happen um but
you have to pick a side
you know and that's what makes it so bad
you can't be like
listen i i don't necessarily support it
i'm kind of the same
look as you and then tim made me feel
bad because he equated it to slavery and
now i feel dirty but um you know it's
i'm the king said with you like do i
like it no would i am i for it no but at
the same time like
i don't know if i have any
ability to look at you and tell you what
you have to do well let me you know just
thinking of something
um slavery is wrong
uh
however
parents
have
legal control over people under a
certain age true certainly it's not
slavery but they can tell the kids
you're going to military school they
can't tell the kid you've got to mow the
lawn and the parents have a right to
tell the kid where they live what they
do until they're of the age of majority
and so i was thinking about that because
it's interesting with abortion
there's also a problem and it's when the
life becomes viable when a child becomes
an adult they are a legal entity unto
themselves and they are immediately
severed and free to live their lives as
they see fit children that want to do
that earlier can file for emancipation
they can be emancipated yeah funny
choice of words right so i think it's
interesting that
there is an age restriction on when
someone can actually dictate your life
to a certain degree they can't beat you
and things like that and then there's
abortion where i'm actually
more of the traditional pro-choice where
it's like pre-viability i i totally
understand what the road decision was
trying to say
in terms of the privacy of the
individual but also
you know
where the government can step in for
medical procedures the problem i have
with it is it's all elective abortion
like 93 it's all it's just use of using
it as contraception and
just i don't know debauchery and things
like that
but i still fall in a more libertarian
side of like i don't know how the
government should be stepping in but you
get to the point of viability now the
baby can survive on its own
now you should not kill it because you
can just
let it live you can be removed i think i
think 99.9 of americans are with you on
that yeah you know what i'm saying but i
think a lot of times people well i think
people don't think that that i don't
think people think that that's what
happens
at least in the conversations that i've
had with people and i think i have a
mixed bag of friends
those that are forward and those that
aren't a lot of folks are like
but that doesn't ever happen and i i
don't know enough about it to know
whether it does or not but you know
those are the those are the the people
that are are anti-abortion those are the
videos that they show right the the
cartoon animation where you're going in
with the forceps and you're literally
ripping the child apart and pulling them
out everyone shows you the most extreme
side of it and so
for me when i when i look at it it comes
in to think at the end of the day the
way i feel personally is like
it's all about responsibility right like
no one
told you that you had to have sex right
and then there were all these other
options that you could have done through
it so for me personally if it was just
my body and i was a woman it's like yo
like
if i'm gonna have a kid
then i'm gonna have it where my issue
comes in is with hypocrisy
as a man
i got no say in nothing but i'm
absolutely on the hook for any of the
financial responsibility you talking
about it from a standpoint of the
child's viable the man has no say in it
at all period like i can't say i want to
have a child right
somehow i'm involved in this process but
somehow i'm absolutely not in control of
this process at all but i'm 100
responsible for the outcome the process
is done and people will always use like
deadbeat dads i'm like
that's that's the same thing like gun
laws like there's laws for you to not
buy guns illegally people do it like but
at the end of the day if you go to court
like i got a buddy in texas
and
texas will literally not give
you will not give you 50 50 split the
mother gets 51 custody
so on the days of this extra day she
always gets the child wow but he still
has a hundred percent child support yep
and she's a job so that's always been my
thing like
i'm cool with the fact that the dude has
no choice no saying the matter but what
i also would like to see happen is if
the dude says yo cool not my body not my
choice i don't want the kid i am under
no obligation to take care of the kid
the man should have that same right to
in my opinion let's keep it fair let's
go to super chats if you have not
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and if you
really want to support our work and you
want to watch the after hours uncensored
show head over to timcast.com click the
join us button and join us we also have
cast castle moving to be a weekly
more sitcom style show we're expanding
it it's still going to be this is
there's still going to be real behind
the scenes elements to the show but
we're expanding the comedy and the humor
because we wanted to do a comedy and
humor show and i got to be completely
honest the vlog just was not really
working so we were like let's let's make
it something let's let's let's transform
it so that's what we're doing ian's been
absolutely slaying on it yeah i'm
produced i'm giving it a little boost of
nitro the only one with any acting
skills in the house
it's working out it's really fun we shot
some scenes today it was great to be
back on set yeah yep and uh then we have
tales from the inverted world so check
that out at 11 p.m we're gonna have the
members only show after dark uncensored
maybe you'll get a little heated but uh
let's read some super chats ian hall
says brain cancer or being a lefty same
difference
yikes
kyle says all my guns are trans muskets
trans muskets are muskets
okay i'll uh i'll have to remember that
galigalov says two nights in a row with
no notification and i have the bell run
for all imagine my surprise you a bunch
of
wrong thinkers lol
yeah smash the um
bell icon i guess
i don't know i don't know if that
matters
all right raymond g maga stanley junior
says thanks guys i was late for work
today couldn't leave my car i had to
finish last night's irl uncensored
substantive inspiring with a pinch of
spice
indeed it was
a hefty show uh a lot of people are
responding to last night's episode ian
i apologize for being heated oh that was
yeah i was thinking the same thing man
you might our friend i love you good
conversation i thought so too sometimes
i get
i feel like my ego is bruised i get
upset but that i still love you and we
need to keep doing this and things like
this yeah i feel like some people might
think like
you know i don't know i actually thought
the good like the heat element was like
it was good i thought it was like
getting that stuff out and having those
conversations 15 at taco bell just
talking about magic cards in the
universe but i'll say that then you know
a lot of people are mentioning last
night's episode we went long was like an
hour
and then i just went off this i went on
this like rant about morality and stuff
and then ian challenged some of my
positions he made good points and a lot
of people were like actually it was
really good so you should check it out
but we're gonna have one tonight and it
should be a lot of fun i think people
like hearing like when people are
passionate about stuff because so often
people are guarded in what they're
saying
it's better that you guys yelled at each
other
i thought it was good
yeah
here we go ehf says tim you should
apologize to ian for calling him stupid
in the member section last night i do
apologize for that you looked and
sounded like a bully ian you good man
your hearts are in the right place and
you have more patience and empathy than
me
don't take anything personally that's
one of the four agreements ah you know
look i get mad sometimes and anybody who
watches a show long enough sees like one
in every 50 episodes where i lose it oh
when i knew you before we were friends i
was like oh i'm gonna go get heated with
that guy like i want to have a
conversation with you like just let it
fly man if you gotta be you know around
people you can trust that you can let it
out with yeah you know yeah sometimes
people get mad especially when we're
talking about such important issues and
stuff that we really care about oh my
gosh we're crafting reality yeah you
know you know
all right kyle army says hartford
whalers
oh my gosh you recognized my shirt
somebody's super chat
it is the best uh
hockey team of all time it no longer
exists through the carolina hurricanes
but uh yeah this is my tribute to
connecticut where i grew up yeah
excited
i hope all of you
so well
looks like the autobot transformer
insignia i love it oh i don't know what
that is but i do know
bobcat says tim why don't you have any
shows about west virginia cryptids
you're in west virginia you could invite
the flatwoods monster on the show if you
wanted just offer him some krigler
coffee he'll show we do have a plan for
that
i don't want to say too much but tales
from the inverted world shane cashman
and the crew jessica
alex everybody's working on this they
went totally overboard uh carter making
the intro song
i was like thinking we're gonna do this
show with 10-minute youtube videos and
then they're like actually made hour
long episodes
it's 10 episodes in an hour long and i'm
like
wow
it's visuals it's audio visual with
sound effects as shane tells the story
of looking for the lost confederate gold
we have several ideas of the next story
arcs which uh i won't say too much but
cryptids may be involved
mobsters
speakeasies we have a whole bunch of
stuff that's uh that we're planning for
tales from the inverted world and we're
gonna keep making it and you know what
i'm realizing too is the amount of money
that it costs to make these shows
it's a lot
but you don't need that many people to
subscribe to the show and so that's what
i'm thinking with timcast.com we have to
stop trying to play this uh this
business where it's like imagine i
started a bakery and i gave away all the
cakes for free but i just crossed my
fingers that somebody would buy the
rights to put their name on the cake and
then it's like well it cost me a million
dollars to make the cakes but i made a
million and thousand because someone
paid for the rights to have their name
on the cakes it's like a ridiculous
business model to be honest maybe
something small scale why don't we make
shows and then just be like here's a
preview if you want to watch it watch it
and then we get a certain amount of
people we can support the show forever
all right let's uh let's grab some more
subjects blue heart says biden cured
cancer cancer attacking itself
i forgot about that donald schoolcraft
says danny retired targeting officer
here thank you for keeping up the good
fight and getting out love what you do
brother ah thank you much
right on
random eskimo says this follows with my
2024 election theory biden says he's
going to run he bravely fights for
re-election and two to three months
before election he sadly is removed and
replaced by not kamala and they push
sympathy vote
maybe yeah maybe maybe maybe
trident 54 says tim allow me to strongly
suggest your first sunday debate
mike glover from field craft survival
channel versus b tatum subject evaldi
police criticism versus a pro-uvaldi
police department position brandon said
today he would be open to a discussion
long live chicken ian
that would be absolutely amazing i
really want to do this sunday uh sunday
debate show
i think that would be absolutely
incredible bring in a couple different
people to just talk about an idea and
hash it out
and then smack the mic maybe yeah there
you go be great
let's do it
all right
colt
m4a1 says get chris hanson on the show
to talk about groomers and predators
oh yeah billboard chris
i love you too
yeah
rainy videos has questioned for ian if
ian believes abortion is not murder in
colorado then did the nazis murder 6
million people the nazis didn't think it
was murder and the principle of the
argument is the same that's a good
question because they did not consider
murder so to a nazi the answer would be
no but to the outside person looking at
it well technically it's still no you
can argue that it's an it ethically
should be treated like murder
and then after the fact they're like hey
now that we're in charge it was murder
you know that so that's where
i don't want that to happen in the
united states where people are like hey
by the way all those abortions last year
they were murders and now you're all
going to jail we got to be careful we
got to be careful that we don't i mean
persecute our own citizens for
this is where i think the viability
plays the biggest role if the baby can
survive there's no reason to kill it if
the baby is able to live there's no
reason to kill it so you hear these
stories from women where they're like
the baby was you know um unable to
survive on its own but it was alive so
they wouldn't remove it and it's like i
think there's a circumstance
where if there is a baby that has no
heart or something that's not viable
like that baby's not going to be born
and live then i then i think i i feel
like these are fake arguments meant to
find an extreme to justify terminating
healthy babies sometimes i wonder what
would happen if you told women like
if you carry the pregnancy that you like
if you don't want to be a mom but you're
pregnant and you care that the pregnancy
to viability
we'll pay for an abortion you don't have
to go through natural childbirth because
i think people who don't want to take
responsibility also don't want to have
to go through labor like you mentioned
that you have two daughters i don't have
any kids but like that seems very
painful and i assume that if you already
don't want to raise a kid you don't want
to have to produce one either it's still
a major surgery but if you told them
look you could just skip birth like
enough of them would opt into doing it
surrogacy yeah
all right you know who says tim kest
just lost half of its paying female
subscribers when ian casually let it
slip that he has a girlfriend
unsubscribed they'll be back
and he can't resist
i actually i'm really excited for cass
castle because i saw what they were
working on today
and i will say this fully candidly
the first part was a little drawn out
and rough and i was like okay i gotta
give you some notes on this but then the
these the plot lines the next two were
just
masterfully done like it it's rough you
know we're look we're not a big
production studio we've got a couple
camera guys and some comedians and we're
making something work but it was it was
good jared's great it's kara's my
girlfriend she's yeah
she's a natural she nailed it yeah it
was funny yeah it was really good thanks
gary love you and then you you playing
the guitar outside yeah yeah so for
those that haven't seen it on the vlog
we did this a bit or at the end of this
bit where he's langston you know what is
it jackson stewart langston stewart jr
the third and it's like ian's a
character so he thinks rocks don't have
magic and but we all know they do
we all know they have magic all right
that's because you're in character right
now right yeah yeah okay i'm still in
character it's gonna be hard to come to
the office i'm getting so confused be a
method actor yeah yeah murph tri says
this will be my last super chat for irl
because i will be upping my tim cast
monthly support another ten dollars wow
i'd rather give you and dan a majority
of my money than have youtube take most
of it from you keep up the fight i
really do appreciate it uh i'm i'm
stoked yeah dan bongino was co-founder
of parallel economy yeah i have the name
let me see if i can pull up the name of
the other guy he co-founded with jeffrey
wernick uh his an angel investor glad he
did and i love the fact that he had more
subs on rumble and then youtube was like
we're banning you dan bongino he's like
i don't care i got more subs over here
why don't i why do i i'm like that's
amazing so um
let me just stress there are many many
more
architectural and structural and
infrastructure changes that are coming
and i'm very excited to announce them
when we can but we've got to build them
so right now when you sign up at
timcast.com no more paypal parallel
economy a dan bongino company proud to
say
all right let's grab some super duper
chats
we got more people saying we got oh man
charlie wilson i think the hartford
whalers are now the most
most rep nhl team on tim cast thanks
hannah go go kanes yes
yeah look guys i there are no
professional sports scenes in
connecticut and uh
their their logo is cool it was designed
by an architect like
i don't think they were particularly
successful team but i love them
nonetheless and if anyone wants to bring
them back i would be all for it a lot of
heart
pine tree squad says tim congress is
attempting to pass h.r 1808 the assault
weapons ban would be an outright ban on
some of the countries most countries
pistols shotguns and rifles this tyranny
must be stopped i did a segment on this
it's a it's it's a near oh outright
total ban yeah it would ban like the
majority of wooden stock hunting rifles
like and i say that somewhat facetiously
like the left is always like you don't
need a weapon of war and they show like
a ruger 10 22 with a pistol grip and
they're like you need a hunting rifle
and they show a ruger 10 22 with a rifle
grip and i'm like you have no idea what
you're talking about but if the magazine
is over 10 rounds and it has like a a
foregrip or a a a telescoping stock it's
an assault weapon
it's like what
that's like everything
it's it's it's nonsense when did you get
interested in guns tim i don't know 2019
when someone tried breaking into my
house
oh that's when you got the musket in the
back that was gonna be that's a good
time to have you got excited about it
well cops told me to buy a shotgun
yeah because a guy tried breaking in new
jersey cops i think the fbi actually
said that the ar is the best home
defense weapon is it though i don't i i
just think that's the i'm almost
positive that they put out a report that
they said that the ar is the best home
defense weapon wouldn't you want like an
you know an ar style pistol with nine
millimeter frangible hollow point or
something like that yeah i mean at the
end of the day i'm i'm not a gun bunny
you know i have i had the pistol by my
bed that's what i have but
i also think that a lot of people
grossly underestimate if i'm just being
transparent their ability to actually
shoot somebody
um you know the first time i put
crosshairs on another human that's a
it's tough that's an unnerving feeling
well you know uh the story from vietnam
50 percent of people
shot they're firing above
the person they don't want to kill him
do you know the psychology behind what
they actually did here what is it so
back in war two i think it was something
i'm going to butcher this a little bit
but you can look it up for the actual
stats i think it was something like 75
of soldiers in world war ii
did not take
a shot on target of first opportunity
and what they were doing they were
training them on the bull's-eyes
right so it's just a pull circle like
everybody's seen for a bullseye
the way they started working around that
was by the time vietnam came around
they started using the pop-up
silhouettes and so when you're when
you're when you have to qualify to with
your weapon you have like two seconds to
engage the pop-up silhouette so you just
get used to seeing a head and shoulders
pop up and then you instantly
um engage and then i think by the time
they said vietnam that the so that rate
had went up to like 70 80 percent of
people took the first now we've got
games like america's army like the first
person shooters that are training people
just to be able to do that i think that
it's like evolving apparently it's like
as few as 15 percent fired their weapon
at the enemy i'm just looking at
random search results and they're saying
75 is a conservative 75 is a
conservative estimate
all right
what do we got here
the clincher says biden slipped the
cancer line in as a cry for help he's
hoping public would catch on demand he
be removed then he can finally ride off
in peace he just wants to sit in the sun
take a nap he is our nation's oldest
president of all time
why don't we let this guy retire
he wants to run again
i don't think he wants to run again i
just think i love when people complain
about it's the old white men that ruin
everything and then you literally
elected the oldest white man in the
country's history
cheese loaf says oh just to clarify on
your statement about soldiers not taking
the shot it comes from a book s.l.a
marshall's controversial book men
against fire the problem of battle
command yeah and they don't know if it's
real no it's not 100 confirmed of course
but it comes from that book
all right cheese though says tim please
tell me that you are still doing what is
an assault weapon this is a moral
imperative yes
but it's very difficult because we need
people now we are having a meeting i
think in the next week or so about
documentary production stuff so we will
get to that
and um i mean it might take a year or so
hopefully it doesn't but the uh
the idea is to do you know it's like
got the start the start of gun control
what's you know what we've currently see
you know are currently seeing with gun
control is it working is it failing and
then and is like potential real
solutions to the to the problem i think
everybody agrees gun violence is bad you
don't want people going around shooting
each other so it'd be interesting to
hear from experts you know what is your
solution then if not gun control and
then we would actually try and you know
address that stuff so uh yeah let's read
some more
chris says tulsi gabbard literally
endorsed biden
yep yeah she was also against nuclear
power and guns ain't perfect but i
thought she was principled and willing
to have a conversation and we
desperately needed that
so
take what you can get man
but uh yeah i'm very critical of her
endorsement of biden
seth hauser says tim harris has a
nervous tic a laughing one i would hate
for her to laugh at at a different
country when in a serious discussion and
start a war or wars with them still do
not want pelosi either
here here
uh eraftis of stett says i appreciate
the hartford whalers tea great guests
you planned wearing that didn't you no
because you asked me 20 minutes to wear
the show i wanted to come home 20
minutes like you're still working how
did they ever go out of out of business
with all these fans the thing is we're
like a cultural institution but we
weren't all in the same generation i
wear this shirt in airports and people
stop me pretty regularly um you can get
them at the bradley international
airport actually if i'm on again i'll
wear my full-on heart for whaler's
jersey uh it's in you know i think part
of it is
states that have a strong identity get
behind their sports teams or whatever
connecticut doesn't have i mean it's
like part of new england it's thinking
it's part of new york like the whalers
are a unifying force
all right
morgan h says my conspiracy theory has
been harris steps down after the
midterms biden nominates a new vp then
resigns shortly after so dems still
incumbent i.e gerald ford
is that what they did with him when
nixon resigned
oh i don't know that's interesting was
ford the vp for nixon before no it was
agnew wasn't it
spiro
i was not old enough i did not exist
back then
the matter that makes up my body was but
a humble banana
all right
ben hickson says ian we love you but you
live in a world of principles while they
play a game of power please watch matt
colville video called diplomacy he's a
dm talking about politics and dungeons
and dragons tim watches video called
politics of war about world war one and
thucydides ooh very interesting that's
cool that's a good idea you know i also
do believe in the whole when if your
enemy thinks you're weak you're strong
like so i i do play kind of ignorant and
dumb a little bit because you can't do
everything on the surface in reality
but i thank you for the for the
statement it's langston
stewart junior the third
get it straight ian's not a real person
there's no ian cross legends never been
an actor playing an actor an actor
playing an actor
that's the best way to confuse people
that's just how good ian is he can play
so many roles at once and comment on
them
the multiverse stop
sam says the democrat perspective and
worldview never changed always elitists
they just made the ruthlessly pragmatic
decision to be nicer in caring for the
lesser people like the poor and
non-white they treat us
uh they they treat us them like pets
no i disagree
uh they're not trying to be nicer to
people the policies then act they enact
hurt people substantially joe biden is
is destroying the is is cranking up the
price of gas personally going to the gas
stations and adding the numbers i'm
kidding but joe biden is enacting
policies that have hurt the price of gas
joe biden allowed for u.s strategic oil
to be sold off to china of all places
and they call me crazy for pointing out
which is a fact so he didn't care about
you he cares about his agenda the
democrats have always been the elites
the the the we are better than you and
we're more deserving than you
i don't think that's ever changed i
think they just try to figure out how to
manipulate to gain power because they
realized they were losing
all right
damon kelly says what's up with the
hartford failures t-shirt oh okay
kevin brady says former tulsi donor here
but i've gone libertarian does it not
weird anyone else uh weird out anyone
else that tulsi has essentially flipped
in many aspects and is also on the world
economic forum website i can't trust
politicians my understanding of the
world economic forum website which
includes her and crenshaw is that it's
an editorial that have nothing to do
with
like how lame would that be
if you're just like minding your own
business and then like media matters
writes a big story about how you're the
best and how you're one of their thought
leaders and you're like i do not work
for these people you know what
we should do that okay who are we
endorsing already tomorrow just like
people people on the left will endorse
be like tim cast thought leader and
we'll like hassan yeah like maybe to a
little overt but then they'll be like
you know we'll put vosh in there and
people will be like why are you on tune
pool's website and he'll be like i don't
know they're like liar i have nothing to
do with this oh my gosh you're our
thought leader we can't help it yeah and
then we'll like i'll send him a present
but i won't tell him who it's from and
then he'll show it on stream
and then we'll include that can we send
him like a plaque being like you're an
official tim cass thought leader
it's like the world economic forum
framing people almost got to be honest
though i'm not a big fan of dan crenshaw
so we've invited him on the show several
times he's agreed and then canceled and
then we and then get canceled again
don't think he really wants to come on
there's a big ant running around over
there what's he doing he's going for
he's going to report to the hive that
there was sugar here we got to clean it
up somebody spilled the sour patch kids
they leave a trail like a chemical trail
wherever they go
nasty little things dude
we've literally been bugged yeah i know
literally
8404 says i start to enjoy ian when i
see him cry on the show when he starts
to believe there's a god but then last
night's members only gets me annoyed
with him
i wanted to read that because i do want
to mention that you are like getting
very emotional over your your godly
revelation
jordan peterson definitely him when he
cries when he talks about what he
believes and people coming up to him
it's uh variance it's it's one of the
most funny yeah they make fun of him for
it i don't know why people i i would
never understand why folks turn on that
dude i am i'm a huge fan of that guy
he's great
he like opened the floodgates so that i
can
it was that it was that line he made
about forcing women to carry babies for
in cells i think you know that really
i'm just kidding
they claimed he did it it was funny
because he talked about enforced
monogamy which is a phrase that
references cultural monogamy like people
choosing to get married yeah and then
they made it seem like he was arguing
that
women should be held at gunpoint like a
handmaid's tale or something
i don't know but you know you know if
you don't know what you're talking about
you should probably google it
andy welsh says regarding hunter filming
his excavates conjure is one of my
favorite lines from the big short
they're not confessing they're bragging
yeah
mad mallard says please look into former
chinese generals buying tens of
thousands of acres of property near
sensitive military and commercial sites
in the middle of the country
particularly next to fort hood and fort
still yeah i heard about that like
what's us
yeah don't like that you know how easy
it is to become an american citizen if
you're rich
foreign citizens will will start a
company in the united states because you
don't need to be a citizen to do so then
they'll hire themselves and offer
themselves you know a visa opportunity
they buy their way in
many countries actually have paid
citizenship though like you can go to a
country and be like i'd like to get a
residency visa a work visa or
citizenship and they'll be like put 500
000 in a bank account we'll give you a
passport new zealand does this yeah i
mean a lot of people have taken
advantage of it yeah are you think
there's people that are citizens of
every country
no
some say some countries won't let you be
citizens of other places like i have
three citizenships but
they're because my parents immigrated
and applied out like some countries have
uh language requirements you have to be
born on soil i have to have a certain
amount of literal residency when my
brother um enlisted in the marine corps
he was an intelligence officer and to
get his clearance he had to renounce his
citizenship other than his american
citizenship so there are we are there
are some countries that will let you
have it and some that won't i know
people who are uh american citizens and
iranian citizens but neither recognize
the other oh interesting yeah
but it's interesting though because when
they do you can get drafted so if if
you're a dual citizen and the u.s
recognizes it and your country has a
draft like
go you're drafted like you gotta you
gotta follow the law man
all right pet detective says hey i
wanted to say i love the show and also i
got to go to my first trump rally he
finally came to alaska isn't it
hilarious no i mean like literally trump
rallies are hilarious the man is a
comedian he's really funny i've been to
so many trump rallies when i was working
when i was covering them i was talking
to people it's just a laugh riot
he's saying he's doing like his
entertainer you know you know he nails
the right-wing jon stewart kind of thing
talking about politics
talking about how people feel and making
it funny and everyone laughs when they
hear it he's calling people out
funny guy when he pointed to cnn you are
fake news and everyone's like wow they
love it i've seen him speak a couple
times and he really can just captures
people's attention i've seen him speak
even like in a serious tone and it feels
very accessible i still think the
wildest thing i thought he said was when
he said when kovitt first popped out i
was actually sitting in a base waiting
on my uh
uh id and he was like he's like they're
asking by kobe's like you're probably
not gonna die from it and i'm like
did you really did you really just say
that he said a bunch of stuff he's like
one day it'll just go away it's like
okay i mean it was right no it's still
around it's just yeah but you don't hear
about it
depends on what you're reading the
people in cities are reading about it
non-stop they won't let it go it's crazy
because i know it's becoming like i
guess it's becoming endemic yeah i know
more people with covet now
i didn't get cody for two years and i
finally got it right
and i knew all these people headed and
nobody was talking about it like at all
but then when everybody was talking
about i never knew i knew i'm not saying
coco wasn't real i believe it real but
at the same time it's like i know more
people now with nobody say anything
about it with it than back when it was
like that's because the media is full of
it let's grab one more super take out
morgan h he says look up gerald ford
spiro agnew stepped down and nixon
nominated ford nixon resigned ford ran
as an incumbent against carter but lost
interesting
interesting uh one more day zen says is
that a classic fender or new release tin
wish i could see the headstock that is a
uh was it brett mason
i love that guitar uh it's it's it's
relatively new custom
really cool it matches your outfits
well i think that's why i chose i put it
there for the colors and everything my
favorite is the harmony silhouette you
can't see over there that thing that's
that bronze looking one no not the
browns one the blue one oh yeah yeah
that's my favorite one plus with the
fender amp it's a it sounds so good we
uh uh we're going over like this the
latest song that carter put together and
i just think it's like i cannot believe
how good carter is carter carter is
amazing
i feel like i used to walk into his
studio he like he's kind of separate
from everyone because the studio's off
to the side and you go in to be like hey
buddy how are you doing i haven't seen
you in a couple days and he'd be like
look at this cool thing like a beard and
he's like a leftover
his application video to tim cast he put
it on youtube it's this incredibly well
edited hilarious video like two minutes
like if you want the benchmark for how
to get hired by a company like tim cass
you gotta look at carter banks
application video on youtube and then uh
i wrote this song on acoustic guitar he
heard it and he transformed it and it's
just like i can't believe how good it is
so anyway my friends that will be coming
out i think the album is going to be
like august 21st or something like that
so we'll see if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
and subscribe to this youtube channel
share the show if you really do like it
post it wherever grassroots marketing is
the most effective thing but we've
recently been doing big marketing we've
got a big time square thing coming up
soon it's going to be epic
because um
you know the time has come to build the
system to challenge the system to change
the rules and uh just to
assert cultural dominance we're gonna do
it
so head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have that uncensored after hours show
coming up at about 11 p.m they go live
you won't want to miss it they're a lot
of fun and may get heated you can follow
me at tim cast everywhere you can follow
the show at timcast irl
you want to shout anything out
soldierfit hey by all means anybody in
the maryland area please come out to the
grand opening of the veterans center on
november 10th and listen if you ever
want to get in shape by all means check
us out soldierfit.com or you can find me
on instagram at sf at danny sf ceo
right on
hi i'm hannah claire b on instagram and
you can check me out on timcast.com i'm
there five times a day and i'm also on
pop culture crisis tomorrow at three
o'clock eastern time
youtube.com pop culture crisis we're
getting them a time square billboard oh
we're getting roberto jr1 and i know
announcing like i said that we're going
to put our rooster on a time square
billboard people are like that's the
stupidest thing i ever heard and i
wanted to say it that way because the
reality is it's actually a big thing for
all of the shows on the website which
includes him he's on the website man
he's a star so it's bogus yeah he part
of the the ensemble is growing uh hey
i'm also gonna be a pop culture crisis
tomorrow oh wait maybe i'm not on
tomorrow maybe you're not but maybe
you're pop culture tomorrow to find out
which of us
find out tomorrow at 3 p.m pop culture
crisis you guys i am ian crossland i
love you very much thank you for coming
danny that was really cool man well
thanks for having me we appreciate it
yeah looking forward to hopefully seeing
we'll definitely see you again man great
stuff thank guys bye yeah and speaking
of pop culture crisis that's where i was
this afternoon it is always a great time
over there and i was telling them you
guys you know
uh uh politics is downstream of culture
this is your selling point have all your
people go on irl and talk about pop
culture crisis it's great and i do think
it is important if you want to know what
a culture really thinks you gotta look
at their celebrities and see what
they're see what they're up to in their
free time you guys can follow me on
twitter mines.com at sarah patrick's as
well as sarahpatchlids.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about 50 or so minutes thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you